In a centrifuge or they spin it in a
centrifuge and extract the medium chain
triglyceride oil.
Pete Holmes,
that's what we're talking about.
Mct oils.
This is what's funny.
Everybody's been asking me why we've
never done one another's podcasts
because we have an absurd amount of
things in common.
I'll give you an example.
I was watching some starlet like in the
writer's room the other day,
starlit I started.
I don't remember her.
Never have used that word.
I'm from the 30th.
I don't know that I was just flipping a
nickel under a streetlamp before the kid
may have a toothpick in your mouth,
but we were watching some startling on
letterman and he was just one of those
great letterman clips,
so it was really just being a dick.
That stuff you don't really see anymore
and I loved it,
but he was making fun of the star lit
because she ate clay and all I was doing
was googling edible cla.
Like I'm that guy.
I'm a believer.
You know what I mean?
Like I'm one of those guys that fucks up
medical studies,
you know what I mean?
Like they give me the pussy and I'm
like,
that works.
That was amazing.
My vision was sharp for four hours.
You know,
what is eating clay do for you?
You know?
See,
that's the thing is if she had letterman
was giving her all this shit and she
couldn't do it,
but I could defend it.
I was like,
if you ate poison and you went to a
regular western medical doctor that give
you charcoal activated charcoal is the
same idea.
These earthy type of things draw out
heavy metals and poisons from your body.
That's not to say that I'm going to go
and eat a clay,
but every morning in my smoothie there's
a shit ton of,
uh,
w we can swear,
right?
Yeah.
Shit.
Ton of Alaris wondered if we could
switch a professional comedian and
youtube too much television fellow.
God Damn the man,
the television man.
Well fuck balls go a shit ton.
I'm swearing about how much Cilantro I
put in my smoothies because Elantra
Parsley,
these do the same type of thing.
Doesn't garlic,
didn't know Rhonda Patrick?
Talk about that.
But regardless,
having some sort of an effect of pulling
heavy metals or attaches itself to heavy
metals,
was it her might have been so many
believers.
So you're putting activate or whatever
it is.
Well,
all is is healthy fats.
Totally.
This is super simple.
Good for your brain.
It's a medium chain triglyceride oil,
so it's the healthiest aspects of
coconut oil.
It's good.
Just get some healthy fats in.
Yeah.
Are you.
Do you do coconut oil as well?
Yeah,
I'm a big fan of coconut oil and those
forks over knives guys.
Have you seen them lately knowing that
they're off oil,
they look like they're about to blow
away.
They're dying in front of our faces.
They're so hardcore now.
I liked that movie,
but those guys didn't see that one.
I don't think it's about the China
study.
The China study has been debunked.
Did you know that thing?
Who tried to scientists getting the
entire Breitbart news staff know the
China Study Alternative facts?
Unfortunately they didn't.
They.
They used some studies.
They use confirmation bias.
These some studies that correlate all
the time.
One hundred percent legit scientists.
Even vegans,
scientists who have debunked it.
Oh really?
Yeah.
I've looked at it and said,
well,
here's the issue.
They didn't bring up this.
They didn't bring up.
That couldn't have been perfect.
It was just a bunch of Chinese,
Jamie and pull something up on it
because there's.
There's been some pretty good scientific
analysis of it.
Analysis.
CCS does that word hypothesis's that
sounds like a wrong word.
Analysis is.
It's like the plural of thesis theses,
which sounds too much like feces.
It's one of those things you never say
no.
Can we go rest in peace?
China study.
Chris Kresser did.
I don't know who that is.
He's brilliant because.
Yeah,
you spent on my podcast for two and he
was a macrobiotic.
I make fun of Chris Kessler and you
know,
I'm just doing a general but he gets
fucked with online,
but one of the reasons why he gets
fucked with his,
because he was a hardcore Vegan and he
was having some pretty significant
health issues and then slowly but surely
switched over.
Oh,
that's interesting.
Yeah.
He.
Well,
it's one of those things like some
people can eat that Vegan Diet and love
great and be fine and healthy.
It makes me feel I'm a.
I'm a flagging.
What's that?
Fish occasionally eat fish.
Fish is great.
I occasionally get drunk and eat
roscoe's chicken and waffles.
The thing is I don't want to be militant
or stringent about anything.
It's just like kind of another thing
that we have in common is consciousness
and all that sort of stuff and I don't
like being rigid about meditating.
I don't like being rigid about any sort
of practice,
including veganism.
So like I tweeted a or I instagrammed a
photo of me at shake shack.
I made a meme that said two drinks,
not Vegan and I look so happy.
I'm like,
I look like this.
I look like a meal and the feet of like
a double shack burger.
It was unbelievable.
Double murder.
I,
you know,
it's really funny because I mocked
vegans all the time.
I had this whole bit about vegans in my
act,
but you will catch me at a Vegan
restaurant at least four days a week.
But you know what you're doing.
I don't know if Aaron Rodgers is a,
not a friend of mine,
but a pal of mine,
all those nfl guys,
you know this.
I'm not going to tell you anything you
don't know about athletes.
They're all eating plant based and meat,
like they eat clean protein and they
plan.
I just do the plants.
I don't like the murder and I don't like
the way it makes me feel.
Frankly.
I like putting things in my body that
are readily absorbed and I said this on
my podcast.
I wonder what you think about this.
I say you can eat a steak for protein.
I'm very curious what you're gonna say
about that because I bet you're going to
school me.
I say you can't eat a steak for protein.
It's kind of like drinking coke for
water.
It's in there,
but you have to do a lot of digesting
and grinding and extracting to get it as
opposed to something that you might
blend and get into your cells more
readily.
Well,
when you blend food for sure,
it gets in your cells more readily so
you could blend the steak.
Yeah,
you can see that,
but I mean if you blend like vegetables,
it's much easier for your body to
process like a smoothie.
Like God damn,
I drank these Kale smoothies and they go
through me like rocket.
And you mean it gives you the shits or.
Well,
not really.
The shits.
It's not.
The shits doesn't get me die unless you
drink too much mct oil.
That's something I should bring up
because it has come up.
If you take too much mct is it
ultra lubes you up inside?
And your body's like,
well that a huge cargo loads they've
been holding onto just your childhood.
Like one of those,
uh,
logging boats tips over very fast river.
Well that's what I see.
I liked that you brought that up is I
eat Vegan to get high.
That's what I'm doing to get high.
Like if you eat three live,
like blue,
green algae,
that's going to ask you about that.
That's really,
really important.
If you do have vegan food and that's
something that Chris Kresser brings up,
12.
Super important,
you know,
it's just,
it's very difficult to get with strict
superintendent for,
to be in the dirt on the dirt.
It used to.
We'd get it that way and now I take it
gets you high.
You can you take that?
There's this product.
I should have brought you something
called the High Huh?
Like,
like,
just feel good.
Just like clean,
like just like a river.
Like you're moving.
Do you think that has to do with like
your placebo effect idea to that?
Like I'm doing good.
I'm eating healthy.
Okay.
That I could not shake shack burger but
I've done it the other way.
I was not a Vegan for 35,
36 years.
So I have the data both ways.
Well it sounds like you're doing it
smart.
If you're using e three live and every
once in awhile you'll be like,
Jesus Christ,
I need some fucking Sushi.
I eat Sushi,
mi or would you be willing to eat eggs
from a chicken that you knew lived in?
Like a yard?
Like something that's like healthy where
you know there's no suffering.
I can dig that and I just want to beefs
I have with Peta is that they have this
campaign against eggs with Peter Peter
with not.
Well I do and I don't.
I like Peter has actually retweeted my
stuff a bunch of times because I'm
really,
really against dolphin captivity and
really against Orca captivity and I say
I think it's slavery that we tolerate in
2017.
I really do.
I don't think it's anything other than
that.
I think those things are arguably as
intelligent as people.
They just can't communicate the way we
can and they don't have hands that
committed pilate objects and create art.
We have a hand.
I have a bit about this.
Why do we.
It's not about dolphins,
but it's like,
why do we eat pigs,
but we don't eat dogs and I'm like
hooves.
The evil feet.
That's true.
Dog with hooves.
Now picture everyone applauding because
I dropped kicked that monster onto a lit
grill demon.
A cloven hooves.
That doesn't need its own chewing cud.
Yeah.
What if you saw a pig with pause point
and if you saw a dolphin with hands or
checking the Khatak no fucking way.
Well,
chickens are dinosaurs.
Chickens are fucking ruthless little
monster.
So say that.
Oh yeah.
I fed my chickens mice before.
I have 23 chickens.
You do not?
Yes,
I do.
I love it.
I get all my.
I ate five eggs this morning from my
chickens.
Shit.
Yeah,
they're like pets though.
Like I go out in the yard.
They're like pets to give me food.
Any attachment to them.
Do you like your chicken?
Yeah,
my chickens died and my favorite one got
killed by a coyote.
That was awful.
Coyote running ran over the phone.
I saw it jump over that chicken chicken.
It's mouth.
Joe Rogan is after God,
man.
Then I found that the coyote was a
mother coyote that had babies nearby and
I felt bad.
I was going to kill her.
Oh,
I was going to set it up.
I was going to leave some food behind
and sniper from the roof though.
Well,
I just felt like she's just doing what
she's going to do.
I'll tell you something funny,
I met with one of the women that like
founded cafe gratitude,
obviously Vegan restaurant,
the Vegan restaurant that's deeply under
fire.
You know the whole story behind them,
right?
I don't.
Oh my God.
What's that?
They.
They started eating meat again.
Who did cafe gratitude.
The people own it really on a ranch and
they started eating meat again and they
started talking about it and they
received death threats and people were
protesting and boycotting the
restaurant.
Yeah.
And they were terrified that they were
terrified.
See,
this is why you got to be a fleeting as
long as you don't stand anywhere to
pescatarian.
Segun.
Segun?
Yeah.
Because pescatarian means you eat dairy
because I don't fuck with daring.
Pescatarian means dairy.
Yeah.
Pescatarian.
I thought pescatarian.
Just fish.
It's vegetarian.
Vegetarian.
That means that she's Vegan.
So fish,
seagate and seagate.
None of these are catchy.
You have to just say league and which
means you can't touch me,
but she told me when I met with her as a
nutritionalist,
and again I,
I might be wrong.
Nutritional list is not a worldly isn't
word nutritionist.
Yes.
Nutritionalist,
I don't think.
Let's make it up.
All kinds of words.
Last night.
I need some help.
Can you help me out?
Give me some over smoking dope.
Brandon goes from right here.
I actually,
I'm on for right now.
Jesus.
Four.
I love four before take the liquid or do
you do the adults?
Here you go fill out a box.
Gives you a box.
Will.
I'll take.
I'll take what it did.
Oh,
thank you so much.
I'm awesome.
Cynthia,
the box was sent to you.
Oh really?
Yeah,
it's awesome.
Please.
I swear it tastes good too.
I'm sorry.
So go ahead Kathy.
But gratitude,
she was like,
look,
if you're not gonna do it if you're a
Vegan.
But she was like the perfect thing to do
as an e three in the morning and one
egg.
She was like,
you should eat one egg every day and
this was good for you.
Clearly there's stuff going on.
Amino acid wise and cholesterol.
Cholesterol is important.
People you.
Did you see the study that came out?
Um,
that was,
uh,
in the New York Times.
It was not a study rather.
But because I want to make fun of,
no,
it wasn't expos in the New York Times
about how the sugar industry paid off
scientists in 19 fifties to demonize
saturated fats and take the blame off of
sugar and for like a really absurdly low
amount of money,
like $50,000.
We were saying,
not even,
I'll kill you money.
Yeah,
exactly.
For $50,000,
these guys essentially changed the way
with this bogus study changed the way
people think about sugar.
Which sugar sugar should be goddamn
terrifying.
I know it's horrible for you.
Did you watch a food choices is a good
one.
Then there's fat up.
There's that sugar film,
that sugar film.
There's a of really good dance where
you're just like,
oh shit.
I had Gary Tobbs in two weeks ago.
He's the author of the case against
sugar.
Kevin Tubbs.
No different guy.
He's a.
If I think of a joke,
I'm going to science journalist and he
wrote a great book called the case
against sugar,
but apparently he's controversial too.
It's a bunch of people are mad at him,
mad at everybody.
These are big lobbyists.
This is going after like cocaine.
It's not that it was.
Other scientists disagree with him.
Other nutritionalist nutritionists.
You make them nice to you.
I'm sorry you put words in my brain and
smoked dope.
Of course I did.
Why wouldn't I?
It's Sunday or something.
I'm not sure what there was.
No,
actually yesterday or the day off.
I didn't.
Um,
but.
Well I should have got high.
Watch the super bowl.
Yeah.
I walked away from the superbowl before
the end.
I'm like,
this thing's done.
Patriots won in the most record over
time.
Whenever.
What do you mean?
Four to 28.
It was down.
They were down 28 to three in the third
quarter.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
Tom Brady,
they say he's the goat the greatest of
all time.
Oh,
okay.
I didn't know that.
You don't know that?
I didn't know.
Not a sports fan.
I met Tom Brady.
Did you give a shit?
I'm friends with Aaron Rodgers.
You didn't feel weird and random.
My Dad has always texting me a painter
towel,
trying to get insider info.
How's Aron feeling today?
I got five grand on.
I fucking give a shit that I had an HBO
special or have a show coming out is
just like,
how's your day?
Tell me what happened is the wants to
wait a little cash.
So let's go back to cafe gratitude.
So this cafe gratitude people.
They decided somewhere along the line
what was really weird because they
connected it to Jesus.
It was,
um,
they,
they had this statement that they made
their jesusy they don't do cheeses,
but they'll do Jesus while they're
older.
You know,
I feel in Anita left for that.
they don't do cheeses,
but they'll do Jesus.
I'm not going to give you a laugh.
I don't understand that.
It's A.
Oh,
he must've not heard.
That's a Tony Hinchcliffe style on human
beings.
Don't like jokes that computers would
get it.
Granted,
no,
I liked them.
I just.
That was,
I don't know.
It didn't get me.
I understand.
You're like,
man,
it is what it is.
I might have laughed.
I like that you're honest there.
Jesus was going to say is I think this
happens to a lot of people to get older.
They start thinking that it benefits
them to have some sort of potential
deity in the future.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
I think they think of the future and
they think of heaven and they think of
Jesus and God and all these,
get the numbers on that.
Like the conversion of people that
become like serious Catholics when
they're 70 might not even be Catholic.
They might go to an alternative sort of
church or you know,
like just some sort of a worship place.
Cc the door and you'd like a friend on
the other side.
Right.
Well,
I,
I think gratitude is incredibly
important and I think like a
appreciation is incredibly important and
one of the things that helps people feel
gratitude and appreciation is a sense
that there's something out there bigger
than you and you sort of submit to that.
And I think when people get older and
their health starts slowly deteriorating
and it's inevitable,
you know,
I mean as much as I'm 49 and as much as
I exercise and try to take care of
myself,
I definitely feel like it's harder.
It's harder to maintain a certain level
of fitness and health.
It isn't as you get older.
Yeah,
and it can have an excuse.
I'm just soft to you.
Can you have an excuse?
You're Vegan.
Tough.
It's tougher.
Oh,
come on.
You've had some of those super fit.
Vegans.
Rich Roll.
Yeah.
You had them on.
Yeah,
for sure.
That it fit his very fit.
Different kind of fitness,
just running for long periods of time.
It's not really no explosion.
No one's trying to kick your ass.
Yeah,
there's a lot millions,
but my point is that I think that folks
as they get older and they feel their
their health slipping and they feel
there's a lot of people that they really
upped their workload as they get older.
Like I talked to Bobcat goldthwait about
that and Henry rollins is the same way.
He's like,
he feels like death at the door and he
feels like he's got to be more
productive.
We've got to get things done before he
goes.
That's funny.
It could go the other way for sure.
You could go more of a Buddhist
threatened be like death is coming.
Why was I so lost in this game?
Yes.
The toasted.
Every time I drink a green juice,
I've said this on my own podcast.
I like to toast it and go,
it won't save.
You know what I mean?
But it was something beautiful.
And a lot of people,
when they're nearing death,
a Rom Dass has a great quote where he's
like,
most people do the most profound
spiritual work of their lives in the
last five minutes they're on earth
because they get it.
You're surrounded by everybody stuck and
lost in the drama of this is important.
And Joe Rogan,
he called me an asshole on twitter or
whatever it is and where there were
suffocating,
you know,
and then they're free.
People that just go,
like,
it was just a game.
It was a dance,
it was a play.
It's a dance.
It's an experience.
That doesn't mean we can't play it.
I think like creative people for some
reason feel towards the end that maybe
they haven't done their best work yet.
Um,
and it's funny that this book is just
sitting here randomly,
but this book,
the war of art is a title.
Have you ever read it?
No.
Please take it.
I've got a bunch of.
I'm going to leave here to the runner up
on double dare.
Steven Pressfield's book.
Good.
Jamie,
take the.
That signed.
One of them is signed,
signed.
Leave it.
I got one for sign.
Okay.
Leave that one.
Yeah,
I'll get you one step of art.
Um,
I bought stacks of them and I give them
to people and press go on the podcast.
That's where this one is signed,
but it's all about resistance and about
how it's very difficult for people
sometimes to just get things done
because they put things off and they
procrastinate and they.
There's this weird thing that artists do
wear a lot of times they half ass stuff
and it's almost like the,
the,
the pressure of creating something,
of expressing yourself,
of doing something that you really feel
proud of really good.
It just,
it's overwhelming to a lot of people and
I think for creative folks as they get
older,
sometimes they,
they feel like there's no time left.
Yeah,
it's time to get going.
Liz Gilbert,
in her book,
big magic talks about how it's almost
like there's a collective unconscious
getting the tank gentle and there's the
ideas and we're almost like fishermen
for ideas and something that I find
motivating.
Like I'm trying to write a book,
I'm trying to do all these things and
I'm like,
I got to reel in that fish before
someone else that's quieter.
More tuned into that.
Unconscious is gonna is gonna get to it
first.
You know what I'm saying?
There's like an urgency.
That's interesting because in an idea
and then like five years later someone
else has something very similar and I an
idea or a concept similar kind of missed
out.
Honestly,
that's not something I dwell on that
much,
but I do see it.
The other thing you made me think of is
Tarantino before he wrote pulp fiction
was like,
I can't die.
He's like,
I just.
I had a fearlessness where he's like,
he was on like a bumpy plane and he was
like,
I'm not going to die.
I haven't finished pulp fiction,
and then he joked when he finished both
fiction,
it was like shit.
Now he became very,
very nervous that he had kind of like
fulfilled his destiny.
Wow.
That's,
that's ego mania.
Gun.
Why don't you think there is something.
Do you ever get in manic states when
you're writing or creating where you're
just kind of like burning clean white
energy?
You're just like,
oh my God,
this is just kind of coming through me?
Yeah.
Well at the moment I start realizing it
at the moment it goes away.
Isn't that a lesson?
You know what I was gonna say to you
that I bet you would like.
I remember being very little and just
being so much more interested than my
other little friends.
At what happens when you close your eyes
and when you're.
When you're laying down at night.
I feel like a lot of people aren't doing
a lot of people that I asked about it
aren't doing the kind of work of like,
what are you seeing?
What does it look like?
Mckenna Terence Mckenna talks about our
dreams are probably far more interesting
than we ever even realize you're
remembered and if you're closing your
eyes as you're falling asleep and you're
paying attention,
if you see something amazing.
Like I remember one time I was feeling
like I was on the bottom of a rocket and
I just saw the exhausted,
this amazing rocket taking me to outer
space and it was perfect.
It was pristine and as soon as I tried
to hold onto it,
it goes away just like that.
Yeah.
That happens to a lot of people when
they experienced lucid dreams.
Yeah.
When you experience lucid dreams,
like you're,
you're awake,
awake in the dream and then you realize
it,
but apparently it's amazing that I
haven't done anything to try to
cultivate this,
but apparently it can be cultivated and
there's a lot of people out there who do
experience lucid dreams and can manage
that dream.
Yoga,
I'm a big lucid dreamers.
Are you?
In fact,
it's one of the reasons I saw a video
where you talked about Alpha brand
helping with lucid dream ticket late at
night.
I always have these fucking trippy
dreams.
Like last night I took Alpha brain
before worked out.
Um,
so it was a few hours before I went to
sleep,
but I still,
I still had some really bizarre dreams
as it's making its way through my.
It's wasted time.
I think there is a parallel to be drawn.
We were talking about the drama of life.
When you have a lucid dream,
I think there's something very in the
Ballpark of enlightenment going on.
It's almost like a play version of
enlightenment.
Enlightenment.
Why enlightened?
Because I'll have a dream that I'm back
in high school.
The classic dream and there's the test
and it's a,
it's a nightmare.
Scared,
right?
I'm scared and it's always like some
history of math class and I'm going
around this very realistic.
I'm in my high school.
The,
the geography is correct.
The people are correct and it's so
realistic that I'm not just panicking.
I'm actually,
the dream is long enough that I'm asking
people to borrow their notes so I can
cram and then there's a lot of
techniques you can do to cultivate lucid
dreaming.
One of them I do all the time as I look
at my hands.
Anytime in waking life,
if something surreal happens,
you look at your hands because if you
look at your hands in a dream,
they always look wrong.
It's a,
it's a giveaway that you're dreaming.
So I'll do something probably look in
your dream.
They look inflated.
They look like those sports fingers.
You know what Mickey Mouse hands.
It's ridiculous.
For some reason your subconscious can
create a beautiful,
you know,
NASA rocket taking off,
but your hands it can't do really turns
out.
You don't know the back of your hand
that.
Well.
And then this thing right here is
actually kind of trippy because this is
what clocks look like in dreams because
it's left brain,
right?
We're talking about this,
uh,
who makes out again,
what does team one made it to the next
youtube clock?
What is the name of the studio?
I just thought it was wrong clock.
No,
no.
This guy is amazing.
He does it all by hands and he by his
hands,
he does it all by hand.
Everything including the walnut case,
tg tgt studio,
tgt studios.
You order them.
He does a car,
cuts the walnut,
and he uses those things inside of them.
Come from Russia.
They're very difficult to get.
What are they called?
Nick's.
Nick's youtube.
What is the next to you right there?
If you had the whole answer.
Um,
but,
but when you're in the tubes,
any clock will look like that.
Oh really?
Because it's the wrong side of your
brain.
What do you mean?
Any clock will look like.
That guy looks amazing.
I might mix these up.
It'll look wrong.
It'll be like,
it'll be 17:00,
it'll be 17,
the symbol for infinity.
And then ideally.
So the clocks will be fucked up too
because the left side of your brain,
I might get these left,
right?
Confused.
But the left side of your brain is what
streaming.
And the right side of your brain is what
controls language and writing are so.
So another clue is if you pick up a
newspaper and notes and it just looks
like Jibberish,
that's a that you're dreaming.
So whichever technique it is,
I'm having that horrible,
very real,
very important.
High school nightmare.
And then you remember that you're
dreaming and you're still there,
but you're liberated,
liberated,
silly.
There's no test.
That's,
that's a little taste of enlightenment I
think as you go,
oh my God,
I was lost.
I was in that dream so hard.
And then you went,
there is no test.
And then you fly to Milan and you have
sex with Kate Upton.
You know what I mean?
Like you realize upton,
she's beautiful model.
I don't remember her.
Oh,
she's the one
with the really big breasts.
Got kind of heavy.
You got to kind of heavy and people were
mad.
It's just took a strange left turn for
Kate Upton.
Right?
She was also,
um,
yeah,
that's her.
Yeah.
You know what's funny,
like whenever I'm in my podcast form on
my website,
whenever people would be bored with the
subject,
they will start putting up pictures of
Kate Upton.
It became a meme or a theme.
She came to a show.
I did a show with jed and.
And you met Leslie Mann.
Nervous.
Look right at her and go,
oh my God.
Yeah.
I just heard the door.
So birds are amazing that through no
nothing.
She did just just random genetic luck.
She has become like,
I don't know what your voice sounds
like.
I don't know a damn thing about her,
but she's pretty much perfect.
Yeah,
she's very pretty.
Some people think she's fat.
Why Do,
if she gained weight,
I probably would just like her more.
Really?
Because you feel like she's human.
Soft,
soft.
I like to like the world to be safe.
Speaking of Tarantino,
there's a great line in pulp fiction
where it goes.
It's a shame that the things that are
pleasing to the touch aren't pleasing to
the eye.
Like you're a hard man.
I bet it's more fun to hug me.
No offense.
Please don't.
Don't let.
It just depends on what you're into.
Yeah,
but you look way better than I do,
so that's.
Thank you for how you look.
You should feel like me.
It should be like I'm a tempurpedic
mattress.
I don't like.
Those are not hard to sleep on a slab.
Harder bed.
I understand.
Yeah.
I sleep on a pretty dense bed.
That's so funny.
Yeah.
You're.
Your sleep number is.
Well,
when I sleep because I don't know what
it is,
man,
but whenever I sleep on a really soft
bed,
get like a crick in my neck or my back.
Felt like a sink in too much or
something.
I understand.
I'm,
I don't have a tempurpedic.
I am the tempurpedic.
Well,
you can get tempurpedic beds that are
more dense I think.
I think they did come and various
density.
They do.
There's a from one.
So anyway.
Anyway,
she's a tempurpedic bed like beanbag.
I call them thicker,
thicker milkshakes.
I like thicker,
thicker milkshakes too.
But women.
Oh,
I understand.
My milkshake brings all the boys.
Are you attracted to women that are as
fit as you?
Um,
I like women to take care of their body
because I think that they have more of a
body awareness.
I think they're sexier.
That's interesting.
Oh,
so you draw an intellectual comparison.
You Go,
you have abs,
therefore you know the science.
They have abs.
I think people who move their body a
lot,
like people who do yoga,
people do gymnastics or martial arts or
something like that.
I think they're more aware of their body
because they're communicating with in an
intense way.
You really.
Yoga.
Yeah.
If you do yoga like all the time,
you're communicating with your body in a
super intense way on a regular basis and
I think you'll just be less awkward,
more confident or more sensual.
I.
I completely agree.
Yeah,
and it helps.
Yoga helps you breathe.
I remember when I did a lot of yoga,
the guy was like,
you'll notice that yogis always brief.
They stay calmer because they know what
it's like.
It's another staffer.
It's another death thing.
It's like meditation.
You're asked to supposed to hurt when
you're meditating because you're trying
to extricate your consciousness from
your body.
You're supposed to hurt.
Like when you're sitting down.
What I'm saying is pain as part of it,
of yoga or meditating and of Yoga.
Yoga,
you could say their pain.
There's pain and yoga and I'm over here.
That's the only reason why I disagree
with you.
My best meditation by far is in a
sensory deprivation tank,
which not only another thing.
We haven't gotten no pain.
It feels amazing.
Yeah,
I wouldn't call that.
Do you meditate?
Do you?
Yeah.
Well I breathe.
My meditation is all concentrating on
the breath deep in through the nose and
out through the mouth.
I take these really long breaths where
I'll breathe in for like almost a
minute.
Then I breathe out for almost a minute.
So you're very difficult to do
oxygenating your blood.
Well,
I don't know if it's that or if I'm.
I'm controlling myself.
I'm exercising my personal control
because you want to just bring.
You don't want to do it.
Like when you take,
try to take a long breath.
Like I'm one minute breath in.
It takes a lot of effort.
Yeah,
I'll for sure.
And to hold it and then breathe out
slowly.
Well that's kind of my point is monks in
the mountains or you in the tank or
whatever it is.
People doing yoga.
There's something bad ass about it is
because you're doing something that
looks like.
When I was a kid,
I just thought monks were relaxing.
Oh,
they just.
They couldn't take the world.
There are too many TV channels they went
up into.
Those dudes are tripping out and they're
denying the pain of their body.
Just exactly what you do when you push
through a workout.
I had a friend of mine,
he became a monk.
Really?
Yeah.
It was a regular dude.
Dunkin.
No different guy.
I don't.
I haven't communicated with them in a
long time.
I'm sure he's not a,
I don't know.
I mean he might be just completely off
the grid now because he dove in
hardcore.
I was probably like 17,
18 years old and he was a guy that he
used to train with and my taekwondo
school,
his name was Joe.
Joe Smith,
last name.
Don't make us trying to remember his
Anyway,
he's a nice guy,
but an interesting guy,
you know?
He was just like cool black dude.
And he started meditating because he
would get real nervous before sparring.
Oh Wow.
Inspiring me.
And I'm real nervous,
so he started to figure out a way to
maximize his physical ability and
potential and he figured controlling his
mind would be the best way.
So he got involved in meditation and
then he sought out lessons at this
Buddhist temple and he started
meditating there and he got super
serious and then he quit his fucking job
and moved out of his apartment and lived
in the temple and just cleaned up for
his food and he became a vegetarian,
very strict vegetarian.
He would eat just vegetables and rice,
that's all lost a shit ton of weight and
essentially stopped training
altogether.
Stop fighting and competing and doing
anything like that and just would
meditate and giving up your life to gain
it.
That's like a Jesus thing and you know,
like a Zen Koan,
like the sound of one hand clapping,
like you meditate on that because
there's no answer to that.
And he had a really weird one.
It was a really weird one.
Something about a dog barking is how do
you know your Buddha nature through the
sound of a cricket and and you're just
supposed to be like,
ah,
I've,
well the crackhead is may and I'm the
cricket and they're just like taken
stare in the corner.
Let's see.
That's pain too.
There's all this like we know in our
life that suffering leads to growth and
it leads to like a cleansing.
Sure.
I had all these things and I think these
turned on guys figure out that they can
manufacture a type of suffering instead
of waiting for it from the world,
which is going to come.
Inevitably.
You can go and sit on a hard ass floor
or you can restrict your diet or you can
breathe in for a fucking minute.
You're causing suffering because you
know on the other side of it,
that's where blesses.
That's where wisdom is.
All these good things.
It's also the understanding that a lot
of your desperate need to breathe.
It's just your brain fucking with you
and you're gonna be fine.
If you take this denial of the body,
like when I've been free diving and
there's a beautiful thing when you're
low and you're like,
shit,
you panic,
and my friend who was teaching me,
he was like,
he calls it second breath where if you
relax,
you realize it's your brain fucking with
you.
It's your brain is like a woody allen
character and he's just like,
well,
we better get up right now.
You know what I mean?
I need you to go shut up woodrow and you
realize you had way more oxygen and you
relaxed and that that's.
I feel like it gets this reputation as
being kind of like a soft or maybe even
like a feminine kind of meditation.
Yoga not so much now,
but it certainly.
My father doesn't think it's cool.
It has definitely a feminine reputation
or weak reputation,
which is insane because it's one of the
most difficult things I do.
I lift weights,
I do martial arts and do all these
different things and I swear to God,
Yoga is as difficult if not more
difficult than all of them.
Yeah,
for sure.
And I'll say you'd probably wait,
I mean you look like you're way a good
amount.
Yeah,
around 200 pounds.
Somewhere on there.
I wouldn't want to throw you.
So if you're using 200 pounds and
you're,
that's your resistance,
it's going to be difficult.
Throw me.
What do you mean?
I,
you know,
I think I would hurt my back if I were
trying to try to heat the martial arts
stuff is the ball pit or something.
I'm seeing like a friendly scenario
where you go please keep me like a
dwarf.
Oh,
do you want to throw me how you got from
Yoga?
Throwing people away enough that I
wouldn't want to throw.
You look at someone and go,
I like to troll you.
You feel like have a small fella.
This is what folks do is we look around
and go,
who in in an order from one to 10.
Who in this room would I tossed first?
Who could I throw the furthest?
I would throw Jamie first,
but for me like there's,
there's moments in yoga class where I
swear I'm tested as much as anything
ever in my
life right now where you're holding a
pose and it's,
you know,
you can keep holding it,
but you know,
you want to stop and you're,
you're whole body is shaking and you
literally see the sweat pouring off your
face and falling off your body.
Especially hot yoga.
Yeah.
Yoga hot yoga class.
Oh.
Literally mean if I do cool yoga,
I'm still the guy with the.
I got to put out the special towels and
stuff.
Yeah,
it looks like a dog,
but I've seen people do yoga on like
hardwood,
shiny floors and you know,
like in or start sweating.
They're slipping all over the place.
That just doesn't seem smart.
No,
that's dumb.
That's very,
very dumb.
Yeah.
It doesn't get,
it doesn't get the respect it deserves,
but I think that,
uh,
you know,
it's also,
there's so many douchebags involved in
it.
That's part of the problem.
Let's go.
Guys ruined everything.
They do body sprays.
I'd like to wear a Bluetooth earpiece.
It sometimes I gave up on them,
I gave up on them when I saw how gross
it looks from people.
It's interesting because you could be
having a meeting on a phone rather a
conversation as long as there's a cord
that goes into your ear.
Yeah.
I would be like,
oh,
he's just having a conversation on the
phone.
That's cool.
But if you're standing there talking and
you're moving your hands around,
you got an earpiece and I'm like,
Douche bag.
Yeah.
And if you leave it on blinking during
dinner,
you are a Douche.
Do they still?
Uh,
I,
some of them,
these two blue blue,
right.
Which bluetooths the guy.
He's got the airpods your buds buds that
are wireless.
They checked out Gary Vee.
He was here the other day.
Gary Vaynerchuk just keep a.
He loves him.
I wonder if when the cordless phone came
out,
anybody who was like,
hey,
that's douchey.
Oh,
for sure.
What do you need?
You don't need a court bro.
You fucking cool.
Oh,
somebody has a bit of that.
I wish I could remember where it's like
the first person that used none Barela.
They were like,
oh,
you're too good to go with.
So I got an umbrella.
Like the latest technology was an
umbrella.
I'm sure.
I wish people,
people are always looking to be upset at
cars that don't make any noise.
Oh,
you're going to look at your car and you
focus.
You're going to hit a cat.
Oh,
what are you using the solar power
instead of dead dinosaurs.
The dinosaurs aren't good enough for
you.
Although fossil fuel wasn't really dead
dinosaurs,
just FYI.
It isn't mostly plants really plant
based Diet.
Well,
it's um,
things rotten,
you know,
but there's a,
there was a book called black gold
stranglehold that I read.
It was so confusing because I was like,
I want to say like at least 15 years
ago.
But the books,
the premise of the book was that what
we've been hoodwinked and that the idea
that oil is a finite resource,
it's not true,
but it's actually a natural process of
the earth itself.
Like,
it'll keep making it a repeating process
in that wells that have been dry have
rebounded when left alone.
Really?
I don't know if it's true though.
That would never looked into it again.
Maybe I live.
We looked at,
maybe we talked about it once during the
show,
but we were probably high
scatterbrained.
I had a great experience in a float tank
the other day.
I've done it maybe four.
Have you ever been your.
You have one,
don't you?
Basement.
That's awesome.
That's pretty cool.
I went to a place called just float and
the first one,
the one in Pasadena.
Yeah.
That's huge.
It's the biggest place in the world.
The Best Company for him.
The biggest.
They have more float tanks I think than
anyone in the world.
Well,
it's amazing because they're doing the
first one that I was like,
oh,
this is like a spa.
Like I've been to the one in Venice at
some guy in flip flops,
like my boy crash.
No Way.
Yeah,
he's kind of built my tank.
He's the best.
Yeah.
Well the float lab.
I couldn't get over the fact that he was
gonna come get me.
Oh,
he's the best night to worry about.
Crashing in the tank was like,
how long have I been in here?
Whose name is a sound effect is going to
knock on the door and it's gonna scare
the shit out of me.
It totally ruined it at just float.
Maybe crash does this now.
It plays music at Lowe's.
You out of it.
A lot of guys like to do that.
It's a good move and it's like a pizza
oven.
It's like a door in the wall and you
crawl in and I had a pretty.
I was trying to go like leave my body
and he ever talk about astral
projection.
Well no,
but I know what you mean.
I was spending most of it being like it
would be so trippy if I just went and
visited my girlfriend right now I
remember.
I'm not saying I did it,
but I definitely didn't do it,
but I remember having this very clear
thought where I was like,
I've always wanted to try a sensory
deprivation tank and I was in it.
So it was somewhere else completely
unaware that I was in it and then I like
jolted back into let's just say my
awareness.
I was lost in my mind so deep that I
forgot where I was.
I forgot who I was.
Very relaxing.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
And it's also something that the New
England patriots use on a regular basis.
How about that?
I really believe the falcons want used
it too.
They put the goat in there.
They use it for all their players.
They use it for visualization.
They usually for recovery,
it's really great source of magnesium
too.
Because the EPSOM salts,
it absorbs through your skin.
Yeah.
Do they change the water?
Yes,
they do.
They do.
And they also filter it out like the
float lab as a really intense filtration
system which uses ozone.
They use these gigantic spa filters and
ozone and like to the point where it
killed everything that might be in that
water except step to you except come
except coming for sure beats off in the
water.
So a friend that went in one and he was
like,
I had to pay.
I just let it go when you want to spend
an hour in your own piss and then as a
whole,
what does that,
the gratuity.
That's an asshole.
That is a real asshole move.
That's the thing that people are fucking
terrified of those things.
Hot tubs and swimming pools,
but they're ruining the communal.
It's like when I was in high school,
we used to have this vat of Coleslaw
that was free and I was such a hungry
boy that I would love the Coleslaw.
Then you find out that jocks are
spitting in it like that.
That's whole ruin everything.
They ruin yoga.
Yup.
Yeah.
Earpieces,
Bluetooth,
veganism.
See that's why I don't want to
be a two associated with it.
So,
um,
pull up the article and that,
that restaurant in La,
what was it called again?
Cafe gratitude.
Gratitude at the article came out in May
of last year,
so six,
seven months ago they found out it came
from a blog post that they had posted in
2015.
So it had gone unnoticed for almost a
year.
Then they were getting a bunch of shit.
Yeah.
They made a blog post about what was
their ranching and farming and that they
started eating meat again.
They felt healthier,
the animals raising responsibly,
but you know,
to vegans the hardcore,
at least it's still murder.
You know,
you're still killing these animals.
I'm a.
are you a Joseph Campbell Felon?
Yes.
Love.
I'm here to return to meet by cafe
gratitude owners,
spark Vegan uproar,
uproar,
you know,
really,
really scary shit because they were
getting death threats,
which is really.
Yeah,
I mean,
just doesn't seem.
It doesn't seem right away,
but you get a lot of that man.
You get a lot of people like,
look what's going on.
Like,
you know that UC Berkeley,
I'm uh,
the Milo Yiannopoulos protest that was
going on a few days ago.
I saw this guy,
there was a girl out there.
It was a trump supporter and she was uh,
trying to,
uh,
I don't know if they were filming her or
what,
but you know,
there's a lot of people out there that
they show up to these things and they,
like,
they want to argue,
they want to make videos and argue with
people.
Some guy hit her over the head with a
wooden handle of a sign and she swung at
the guy and another guy got in front of
her amazed or in the face and there's a
video of this and you're like,
Whoa,
you guys,
you guys are the kind people that don't
want this man.
Who you think is,
you know,
they keep calling him a Nazi.
It's hilarious because he's a gay Jew.
Milo Yiannopoulos was Jewish.
Her doing it.
Okay.
So she's wearing a make America great
again hat and some guy comes across.
This is not the video that I saw.
I saw it from a different angle,
but they take her,
she gets pepper sprayed.
Are they showing it?
They're not.
They might.
Oh,
okay.
That looks right there.
She just gets pepper sprayed,
like cc it towards the end.
It's crazy.
Somebody just pepper sprayed her just
just because she's wearing that hat,
which is what it is.
Look,
that's a fucking man.
Just walks up to her and pepper sprays
or in the face.
It's crazy.
The idea that you think you could do
that just because you don't agree with
that person.
Thoughts.
You can choose violence because you
don't agree with that person's thoughts.
Instead of having a civil debate,
she's not.
She's not as threatening.
She was not physical.
She's not doing anything violent.
We're missing a mythic hero.
You know?
A lot of people want Bernie Sanders to
be that guy,
but we don't have a Martin Luther King
that's telling us,
listen,
only love can drive out hate.
Only light can draw darkness.
So you ended up with a
lot of people that don't have a
narrative or a story or a or something
in common,
and then you just have people kind of
running it however they see fit and some
people are stupid and they're going to
pepper spray paint.
Well,
there's also this.
Is this her getting,
this is another angle of it,
paid for it.
So she's got this hat on in a free
country.
I mean it's fucking insane,
man.
That someone could just walk right up to
her and pepper.
Spray her in the face just because she's
wearing a hat that supports Donald
Trump.
You know,
if you want to talk to someone,
you talk to them if you don't agree with
them,
have a conversation with them.
But there's this narrative that's going
around and it's punch Nazis,
right?
People keep saying that so.
Well,
who the fuck is a Nazi?
Who Do you determine as a Nazi?
You decide they're a Nazi and then you
punch them,
right?
Do you have evidence of this person's a
Nazi?
Do you.
I mean,
do you,
do you see them?
Do they have a Nazi flag on them?
Are they saying Sieg Heil?
Do they have a copy of mine comp?
No,
you just decide wearing the halloween
costume.
So here's how it goes.
Here's the thought process is if you
want it to fall like on a flow chart,
it's like decide someone's a Nazi,
then you can punch them,
punch Nazis,
find someone.
Are they a Nazi?
I say yes.
Punch them,
and so there's this.
There's a bunch of people like
respectable,
intelligent people that are just plain
upset that trump is the president.
Just plain upset that in their eyes,
and I think rightly so.
There's a lot of assholes that support
trump and there's a lot of assholes that
are now gloating and they didn't know.
They're like,
grow up,
you lost.
We won.
There's all this going on,
and their response to it is now those
people are Nazis.
Go Punch Nazis and these really
impressionable people are out there.
Punch them.
Do you see jake shields,
the former UFC fighters in mma fighter
is a good friend of mine.
He had to save some kid who was getting
beaten up by a whole group of people
just because he was a trump supporter.
He didn't do anything.
He was just there at this thing and
there's a few people that were,
you know,
trump supporters or Milo yiannopoulos
supporters and the rest of them were
people that were mad that Milo was
playing there.
It's,
it's so controversial and so fucked up
and so wrong because the left is now
becoming the right.
Like you're becoming a fascist by saying
it's like a one stop fast.
It's like a weird twists in the movie.
Yeah,
I,
I love the.
There's a kabir quote where he says,
do what you have to do with another
person but never put them out of your
heart.
And I think that's a great way to
remember.
I was with rammed us with Duncan in
Hawaii and he said,
I hate Donald Trump here,
not here.
He pointed to his head and it's not as
hard.
And then the thing that I love,
and this has been a mantra for me for
ever since I've heard it,
so it's been about a year,
but it's very applicable now,
I think is that hate is a lack of
imagination.
So when you see somebody wearing a hat
and then you make all these assumptions,
but you're not taking the time to
consider.
Maybe this person was raised different
from me.
Maybe this person is scared of this,
this or this.
Maybe they had medical issues.
You know what I'm saying?
Is this great David Foster Wallace
thing?
Were you in that great
graduation speech he gave called?
What is water?
Have you heard that?
No,
it's amazing.
But he talks about when you see an suv
on the highway and you just assume that
there's some like piece of shit changing
lanes,
fucking burning gas,
taken up the world like a real kind of
like a shorts and a grid out guy that's,
that's a dick and taking more than he
deserves it.
He's like,
that's a lack of imagination.
If you consider that,
maybe that's a mother who was in a
terrible car accident that was all but
prescribed to drive a big vehicle so she
would feel safe.
Again.
That's what I'm talking about when you
see someone wearing a hat and you just
go,
well that's a Nazi.
I'm going to punch it.
You're not taking the time to not just
have empathy,
but actually compassion and realize that
we're all in this together.
I remember after after trump won in the
green room of a comedy show that we.
I did a show the next day and somebody
was having like a full blown panic and
rage and talking about how the
terrorists,
we're going to test him,
like the terrorists are going to test
them.
They're going to,
they're going to do this and this and
really panicking and it really kind of
gave me a little bit of perspective on
it.
I was like,
if Hillary had won,
we not us,
but other people who are just like us
would be somewhere else in some other
comedy club and some other greenroom
complaining about how the terrorists are
going to test hillary.
She's weak.
She's a woman.
They're going to test her and it just
made me realize,
shit,
we're all in this together.
That's what I mean.
Beyond empathy into compassion.
When I see someone in a red hat,
I go,
there's my brother and my sister,
a different life,
a different path,
playing a different part,
but we're,
we're all part of one body and pepper.
Spraying that body.
You're just spraying yourself.
I understand rage and and protests.
You know what I'm saying?
I don't agree with trump.
Here's the thing,
but violence.
We're hurting ourselves.
I think you're right about a lack of
creativity or a lack of imagination and
being able to look at that person and
say,
well,
how did that person get to that point
and what went wrong in their life and
why are they here?
Where the,
you know,
are,
uh,
you know,
whatever it is,
whether a pepper spraying somebody or
protesting against something or you,
whenever you have a cause and you have
two sides,
people are going to jump on one side or
the other.
It's just natural.
People want to be in a tribe.
They want to be on a team.
And when you set up the narrative and it
really dangerous narrative that people
on the other side of fools,
people in there to sutter evil people in
the other side of the you,
you set up these two camps and these two
completely different sides and it
becomes a black white issue,
but it becomes a red state blue state
issue.
And this is what you're seeing here.
You're seeing fights.
These are tribal because it is us.
As soon as we come and ask,
they become with them what or had isn't
even a trump hat.
It says may make bitcoin great again.
It's a big one hat.
Oh Jesus Christ.
What if I was suddenly so that guy
pepper sprayed her and he thought it was
a make America great again hat Jesus
fucking Christ.
Oh my God.
It's just assholes.
You know?
And not only that,
most of them are wearing face masks and
they're covered in.
There's
a mob mentality that is a very real.
It's whatever condition,
whatever it causes it in the human
psyche.
But something happens where there's this
diffusion of responsibility when people
act in large groups that allows people
to do really heinous things and it's
been studied,
you know,
there's been psychological studies drawn
on it or done on it and it's really
confusing.
But you know that poll,
everybody if you ever been in a riot
type situation or in a group situation
where there's a lot of people and
something goes wrong.
It's really weird.
There's a weird feeling that happens
when a large group of people.
I was on the subway going downtown to
the women's March and it was getting so
packed that people were starting to
panic.
A kid threw up and stuff and I was going
to shit.
I forgot what it feels like to be with a
lot of us when we start getting scared.
But that's the beginning of imagination.
That's the beginning of coming up with
some sort of game plan for compassion
when we can sit down and have a
discussion.
I'm not saying don't make signs and
don't raise your voice,
but I am definitely saying,
don't pepper spray somebody that's in
this world with you.
That's like trying to figure it out the
best they can.
You know?
I mean,
this don't make sense.
Don't raise your voice.
It's always a good thing to discuss
things.
Right?
But what's wrong with these discussions
with the Milo Yiannopoulos thing is
they're trying to stop him from
speaking.
If you want to get your point across
schedule,
debate,
he'd be more than happy to debate you
and do it in a respectful manner where
you can try to pick apart his points.
I've had milo on my podcast,
I've picked apart his points,
I've had him on and we've gone back and
forth on the important shit like
religion and circumcision and this.
You can have a conversation with the guy
and what he's doing is he is getting a
fuck ton of attention through the
streisand effect.
When you try to silence him by pulling
him out of these,
these things just for speaking and he's
not doing anything wrong.
He's just speaking.
The university has allowed him to be
there and then people are going crazy to
do $100,000
worth of damage to the,
to the university,
and then the fucking mayor of San
Francisco congratulates people for
speaking their mind.
He congratulates people for expressing
themselves like,
no,
that was a fucking riot man.
Like do you understand what happened?
100,000
dollars worth of damage and people
getting beat up and a girl getting
pepper sprayed for wearing a bitcoin
hat.
That's not good man.
I know you want to be progressive and I
know you want to be liberal and I know
you want to be the mayor of the most
progressive place,
but this is all the wrong message.
The correct message is calm dialogue.
People discussing things will keep calm
and remain calm and carry on.
So this guy,
Milo,
when you're fucking screaming and
yelling,
he wins.
When you stop him from doing that,
I think he sells more books.
You're also making a bigger point,
I think,
which is when we become us and we let
them become them and we lose of the fact
that we are all part of one body.
I mean when we shine it superorganism
yeah.
Talk about wanting to belong to a clan.
We do.
We belong to a very special group.
It's a trip that you're here,
that you are here at the same time.
I'm here and we're here talking.
That's beautiful.
That's what I like.
Hippie.
I thought you've taken lsd one time.
Sticking together.
I'm already on it.
I wish I were.
I'd be.
I'd be going off even deeper,
but I'm just saying when you take
psychedelics,
you do get that glimpse into your like,
you know when you give.
So if I give you a gift,
if you give me this book,
it's really just the right hand giving
something to the lefthand.
It's all one thing so it doesn't work to
fight against ourselves and it's not
good to call somebody them and to be
divided.
Well,
it's also,
there's no communication going on when
you're screaming and lighting things on
fire and breaking windows at starbucks
that's not communicating.
You know,
you're expressing your anger that this
guy who says that feminism is cancer,
talk to them.
Try to figure out why he's saying that
we have a debate with them.
If you disagree with them,
find out what he's saying that's not
valid and have a counterpoint to it and
that's how people get to share ideas,
express themselves,
and then the people watching get to look
at it and go,
well,
he had a point,
but then his points better and then you
figure it out and that's the marketplace
of ideas and that's how human beings
communicate.
And as soon as you stop that,
as soon as you stop free speech,
you fuck the whole God damn thing up
because now you have decided that you're
a fascist and you're saying that your
ideas are more important than other
people's.
Don't you do a good devil's advocate
person,
but don't you worry that some of the
people that are making more base kind of
dismissive generalizations like feminism
is bad and Muslims are bad,
right?
Aren't necessarily listening to an
intelligent dialogue,
so therefore isn't there sort of like a
cause and effect of like,
this is some crazy shit.
We're going to do some crazy shit.
Some
of them listen to Doris writing pepper
spray and some of them aren't listening,
but I think you always have to appeal to
the higher side of human consciousness
and you always have to express yourself
in the most articulate way that you are
capable of,
so you should try your best to get your
thoughts across and it's not always
easy.
It's oftentimes very difficult,
especially when emotions are involved,
especially when you think this causes
very important,
but I think it's critical because you're
doing something in a very public way,
right?
Because this is something that people
are going to talk about for months and
months.
There'll be talking about the UC
Berkeley riots for a long time.
It's very critical.
I think whenever you're dealing with
something that is going to get massive
exposure like that to do your very best
to communicate your thoughts without all
this extra bullshit attached to them and
anger and screaming and yelling,
don't get lost and don't get lost in it
and and figure out a way to vocalize,
to articulate the the,
the reason why you feel a certain way
and what you have thought about it.
Not,
not,
not some knee jerk bullshit that's easy
to dismiss.
You know,
Muslims are bad,
this is bad and that's bad and feminism
is for full composed w not that way.
Now to express why you think Milo's
wrong.
Express why you think he's right and
that's the marketplace of ideas and you
might disagree with that person that
you're talking to,
but you've got to let them talk.
You got to let them talk and then you
got to figure out a way to counter what
they're saying.
I,
again,
not a good devil's advocate.
I think people worry when we let these
people talk and I went to it.
When you say these people though,
Milo is not something to worry about,
he's not a guy who advocates violence.
He's a really interesting guy to talk
to.
He's kind of a troll.
I mean what he's doing is fucking with
people and it's really accurate and it's
really what he's doing is being very
effective and he's.
He's getting people to buy his books.
He's getting people to come to his
lectures is getting people.
When he got banned from twitter,
that was probably the best thing that
could've ever happened to him.
He did like a hundred interviews
afterwards.
It was on CNN.
Even cnn they're doing like CNN supposed
to be news,
right?
So He.
They have a photo of him.
Ridiculous photos were in a fur coat
with sunglasses on because it's so silly
and it says Milo Yiannopoulos is trying
to go to colleges to convince them that
hate speech is cool.
Like how the fuck is that an article on
CNN.
How is CNN saying that?
Because that's not what he's saying.
He's not saying that hate speech is
cool.
Look at that right there.
Miley Annapolis is trying to convince
colleges that hate speech is cool.
How the fuck is that?
The News?
It's not the news that is heavily
editorialized that it.
That's a ridiculous.
You're taking a stance on his opinion
that he would rabidly disagree with and
it's not right and this is.
This is left versus right.
It's like CNN is the new Fox News.
CNN is the sky's falling and the world
is shared and we're fucked,
and Fox News is now all of a sudden the
grass is green and everything's rosy and
we're making America great again with
bizarre.
It's interesting because you're trying
to zoom out and I think that's one of
the things that's very integral to kind
of getting through a time like this is
zooming out and going,
yeah,
look,
looking at what's happening in a big
way.
We're becoming what we don't want to
become.
We're becoming militant.
We're becoming violent,
we're becoming fearful,
and I would.
I wish there were more opportunities to
have,
I guess these,
these dialogues that could be done
peaceably well.
I think there's an issue also in that
people do not feel like Donald Trump
represents what they think of as a
leader in their mind and a lot of
people's mind and in my mind,
Barack Obama was an amazing leader and
people will get mad and pissed at you,
especially conservatives.
We will.
What are you prone to?
Listen,
that guy was smart.
He was articulate.
He was calm and measured.
Any always seemed like he wanted what
was best for the country.
Whether you agree or disagree with this
policy.
He and my mind was very statesmen like I
agree the way he would say when you're
in,
when you're playing a part,
the president.
I'm not saying the president is a
puppet,
but I'm saying part of it is the
mythological role.
I am the president and that's why people
talk about acting presidential because
how much of it is that?
How much of it is the way you handle
yourself and the way that you treat
other people and the way that you tweet
or the way that the apprentice sucking?
Yeah,
sad period.
It's.
It's a strange.
It just.
Even the vocabulary,
I see a lot of the trolls using some of
the same.
Yeah.
They're saying don't do that too.
They say sad at the end of the surgery
on Joe Rogan's podcast,
sewing up behind president.
You know,
funny.
Anyway,
said Cook,
how did this.
What's it like to be a cook?
Well,
it happened because that's what one.
That is the response.
We tried one way we didn't like it and
now we're trying the other way.
It is.
It's a classic example of what human
beings do.
Yeah,
we don't.
Well,
that's zoomed out.
I like that.
Well,
I don't think that the idea of a
president is the smartest idea to run a
group of 350 million people that are
trying to integrate and communicate with
the other 7 billion people in the world.
Democracy isn't the best form of
government.
It's just the safest.
It's good to quote,
safest.
We have A.
Patriarchy would be far more.
This is what they were like.
If you had a benevolent ruler,
like a really big good one,
that would be more effective,
but it's too risky to do that.
Way Too risky.
It's just contrary to human nature and
absolute power corrupts absolutely.
That's a wavy gravy is easy.
Great.
He was as kind as he is.
I think he's still alive.
This like weird hippie guy that kind of
like the comedian of the time we did all
the psychedelic koolaid acid trip bus
thing.
He had a funny joke where he was like,
he wanted to nominate nobody for
president.
It was like we should vote for nobody
because nobody can do it,
but it had all these funny slogans were
it was like nobody can solve our
economic prowess problems.
Nobody cares about you.
Like all these funny thing.
It was like,
and more people vote for nobody than any
other candidate combined.
We got to get nobody in the office.
Do you see what Neil degrasse Tyson
posted?
He said there should be an option for
none of the above.
Then if none of the above winds,
we start the process all over again.
Why?
I think a lot of people would have done
that.
I think that's a great idea because to
make this artificial limitation like,
okay,
these are the people.
It isn't able to grasp,
so I shouldn't be surprised how many
people would have lined up and gotten
all around every way.
They wouldn't have been live.
Tried to vote to have been like,
I'm voting that we need to go.
We need to go back to one for,
for president.
All the other things.
You get to vote for it and then for
president vote none of the above.
I bet it would have been like 70 percent
of the country.
I would have been.
It would have been.
Would it have been something crazy?
You would have done it just for the
novelty of it been like I was the first
one to vote.
None of the above.
Everybody wouldn't.
You wouldn't been the first would know
what?
I think it would have been most of the
country because I think that even if you
were opposed to trump,
there's very few people who thought that
Hillary was the ideal candidate for.
She was incredibly flawed.
She had deep,
deep ties to financial institutions.
She wouldn't release the transcripts
from and people get so mad
when you talk about these things.
You're the reason why trump won,
bro.
You're a big part of it,
man.
You kept harping all the problems that
Hillary has said.
You're not supposed to ignore what's
real and true and obvious about a
person.
If the other person has flaws as well,
that's not how it works.
That's just,
that's how you box yourself in and put
blinders on.
That's not lifting up and looking at it
objectively right above there.
The reality is it's an insane job to put
one person in power of all these people.
I think there should be a large group of
people.
It should probably be chosen by a large
group of people.
I think that voting should be far easier
than it is.
I think registering to vote should be
far easier than it is.
It should be something as simple as you
have a social security number,
punching your social security number.
Oh,
it shows here you're over 18.
Yes,
you can vote.
It should be that simple.
Are you not a felon?
You're not a felon.
Okay,
great.
You can vote to vote online.
Have a light buzz on.
Shouldn't there be like maybe some sort
of a,
just a,
just a very light test to determine what
your understanding is of these bills,
what your understanding is about the
impact of these things,
what your understanding is about what
this entails.
I always think it's the immigrants that
understand that stuff because they had
to go through a very rigorous process
and then you asked me what the bill of
rights is and I'm like,
oh,
Bob care.
When I was a kid I used to deliver
newspapers.
When I say a kid,
I was driving,
you know when I was 16 and 18 and when I
was delivering newspapers,
there was this guy named a non,
a non and a n a n d,
this Indian gentleman who used to work,
he was a pharmaceutical expert in his
country,
but when he came to America,
he,
his degree didn't translate over here
and so he's becoming an American
citizen,
so he would always.
He was.
He was a hilarious little dude.
He used to swear all the time.
I weighed about 100 pounds and he'd be
like,
I could easily throw them.
Yeah,
you could throw him like a beach ball.
He's like,
you don't know shit.
Nobody knows fucking shit.
Nobody knows shit in this fucking
country.
What'd you do in this fucking country?
Who come here and then you'll go home
and go to sleep.
You don't fucking know shit about your
fucking laws because he was trying to
read all this stuff because he had to
become a citizen so you to take all
these tasks and so he was a.
He would ask me questions,
do you know you know what the 13th
amendment is?
Do you know what the 14th amendment?
It was like,
and I believe I don't know any of these
things,
and he'd laugh and get the fuck out of
here.
Go do your route.
Which is a real friendly kids.
Children.
Exactly.
You know what I mean?
We don't know the value.
We don't have to.
We don't have to and people tend to do
what they have to do.
I think the way you become an immigrant
in this country,
we have to go through a comprehensive
test and you have to understand the
history of the United States.
That test should probably be what you
have to go through to vote.
It's funny because I'm agreeing with
you,
but we're.
What I'm agreeing with is we should
simultaneously make it very,
very easy social security number and
very,
very difficult.
Very easy to be registered to vote,
so it's not something go up.
You missed the deadline.
Fuck
you.
Your vote doesn't count.
How quiet would the line be to vote?
Would all be studying like popped one
random question and it was like
Frederick Douglass,
20 minutes you'd have to do it online
and if you did it online you'd be able
to cheat.
But even if you were ever to achieve,
even if you were to what's more American
than that,
but mean be looking it up on Google.
Right.
But even then at least some of that data
is going to get into your fucking head.
Yeah,
right.
I mean that's gotta be better than the
understanding that most people have.
Whether it's historical or whether it's
just a comprehensive understanding of
how our electoral process.
Because googling it doesn't stick.
That was tom's.
It does.
I don't remember shit like I have to
listen to things about three,
four times before I finally,
but don't you think it's because they
don't have like an emotional connection
to you?
Look,
if I read it's really important.
Yeah.
Well I had a bit about.
Well where I was like the time between
not knowing and knowing is so brief.
There's no feeling associated with
knowing like you don't get adrenaline
and adrenaline is linked.
Linked to memory,
like adrenaline is linked to memory.
Oh yeah.
This is right up your alley.
If you're ever trying to memorize
something.
College kids listening,
get to studying for a test,
dip your arm and ice water every 30
minutes or whatever.
It will become a traumatic experience.
It will help you memorize.
This is why we have a hard time for
getting trauma,
so it's a very light trauma.
Oh,
that's interesting.
Or a trauma by just ice water,
which is not that traumatic at all.
Big Old tank and dunk here.
They,
they've done controlled studies and
memorize.
What a great idea.
Well,
that seems to be like you could memorize
things really good in a cryo tank if you
did like crow genic.
I've never done that.
Have you?
I do it all the time,
dude.
You fucking feel it.
That's 250 degrees below zero.
Is that unbearable?
Yes.
You do it for three minutes for some
reason.
Okay.
Three minutes.
For some reason I was like,
they figured it out a way to make you
cold,
but you don't expect it.
You know?
You experienced the fucker.
What about infrared Saunas?
I did one this morning.
Great.
I don't fuck around with that.
Joe Rogan is good for you.
I spent messaging for a mixed blessing
for memory,
stress in the brain,
brain connection.
The limbic system includes the
hypothalamus,
the hippocampus,
and these only one Jamie.
He just throws it up on the board and
the Amigdala and other important brain
structures that govern emotional
responses,
behavior and longterm memory.
The release of adrenaline increases
levels of activity of these areas of the
brain has been associated with improved
memory.
Isn't it funny like the words that he
googled our bold this we were living in
the future.
So amazing.
But the bit I had was that Google's
making A.
I think it's one of the reasons I got to
do a talk show after Conan and I did
these two Conan's sets and I think I
picked good material and the first one
was about how google is like a
calculator that helps you cheat at
everything that's funny.
So you don't know anything.
And the example I give is there was a
time like I've been in bed and I'm just
like,
where's Tom Petty from mean?
I just look it
up.
Running.
That was a real example,
but back in the day,
if you didn't know where Tom Petty was
strumming,
you just go around and ask people lie
jail bro.
He was born in Asia.
Ah,
and they'd be like,
holy his long hair.
He looks like California,
maybe California.
Then one day you'd meet a girl and the
heartbreakers tee shirt and she'd tell
you Florida and endorphins and
adrenaline and all this things would
light up in your brain and you remember
that moment for the rest of your life
and that's how you met your wife.
He's one of the few awesome things from
Florida.
There's like Leonard Skinner,
Tom Petty,
Billy Corbin,
who was doing cocaine,
cowboys,
Disney world,
but in la,
what's better?
Disney world is supposed to be bigger,
right?
I like Epcot because I'm 37 years over
there and they eat babies.
Remember that kid got snatched up.
Fuck alligators.
There's no at Disney land.
I know there's cougars though.
Chicks.
Yeah.
Lip Jobs.
I will.
I buy into Disney.
I'm embarrassed.
I want to be like,
fuck this shit.
This is.
You have children know when you have
children.
Disneyland becomes a magical place.
It already is,
but it really is.
If you have children,
some children in the big golf ball in
the big golf ball.
What's up,
bro?
Oh,
hap.
But I was really young.
I haven't been to Disney world.
I went to,
I did a corporate show at Disney world
and it ended at like 10:00
and they'll keep one park open till
midnight or something,
maybe it's 11 and uh,
I went up but you couldn't buy tickets
until they stopped selling tickets at
eight.
So I went up to the gate and I'm talking
to the girl that I'm trying to get into
epcot and you know,
they're,
they're so trained to be good at
customer service,
so they're just like,
I'm so sorry sir,
you need a ticket and you can see the
town.
They're from like,
come on daisy.
I know they'd raised you better in grand
rapids.
She's like,
I'm so sorry.
And people are walking by going like,
Hey,
great show.
I'm like,
and she was like,
I'm so sorry.
And I,
and then they opened the gate for a
woman with a stroller and you stuck it
in and I just went like,
I just put my hands up and I was like,
daisy,
I'm so sorry if,
if anyone asks,
I'm going to say that you tried to stop
me,
but I'm going in what she do.
She was just like,
please don't please.
I was Kinda,
I was kinda being a dick,
but she was just like,
please don't please don't.
And I walked and you go over this bridge
when you get in,
and as soon as I got over the bridge I
felt like a refugee.
Going back to Tom Petty,
Holy Shit.
One of the best nights of my life,
my heart closed.
We had some Saki.
I was with this young lady that was
organizing the event.
We had soccer,
soccer,
soccer.
I play soccer.
I don't know if I've never heard anybody
say soccer,
but I think you're right.
But we drank it and everything in epcot
is unlocked so the park is closed.
It's dark and we're waiting to get
kicked out and we're opening every door
going into rides that have been shut
down.
It was one of the more hands in the
gears.
What makes this thing work?
My finger was there,
could turn it off.
It was going that way.
It cut my hand off right here.
Then I jumped fences and swam and every
pool.
I-Pass.
No,
you did.
And it was one of the best nights of my
life.
You jumped fences.
Once you broke one law,
you're like,
fuck it,
I'm a rebel.
You get a little sack and you.
And then you get the feeling of
entitlement that Disney provides.
They make you feel so important.
It's one of my theories,
but I think rich people are assholes,
is because have you ever stayed at like
a four seasons or something?
Then if you say at the four seasons and
they love you and,
and they're,
hello,
Mr Rogen,
we noticed your room isn't quite ready.
Here's a Mai Tai.
You know what I mean?
They just kiss your ass so hard.
Then you go,
I had this happen.
I stayed at the four seasons in Hawaii
and then the next week I was on the road
and Portland and I was staying at a best
western.
I was just like,
this is why rich people are dicks.
Because I was like,
sorry,
your room's not ready.
And I was just like,
could you call me?
When they looked at me like I was
insane.
They were like,
no,
I'm not going to call you when it's
ready to go get a fucking hundred grand
bar and sit down.
Nobody cares.
Sandbar John Molina is the best bit he
did snl.
I tell the story like it's my own.
I don't even give a shit.
He was writing for Mick Jagger on snl
and it really helped me understand why
rich people and celebrities can be rude
because he's watching mcjagger go like
diet coke.
You know what I mean?
Not being an asshole,
but also not being like,
hey,
how's it going?
Joe?
Could I please get a.
can I get a diet coke please?
That'll be so great.
I'm trying to write a new song.
He just goes diet coke and Malania was
like,
I get it.
You're not polite to Siri and when
you're that famous,
everyone is Siri checks.
Mix,
shuffle the rolling.
So you know what I'm saying?
Do you know what Siri is?
Just because this is the way you know
that you're talking to somebody.
You know they're not Siri,
but they become Siri.
If you have five decades of everyone
kissing,
you need to do acid.
If that's where you're at,
you need to do mushrooms,
you need to do something,
you eat a cookie.
I said many times my fantasy people have
like weird fantasies about getting trump
out of there.
My fantasy is,
is turning them on.
Oh yeah.
Get them on some dmt and let them bring
them to the center of my universe.
Texted me a fake photo.
It's trump with a beard and it's on Fox
News and it says lsd saved my life.
I was like,
this is just a guy.
I just want want them to take mushrooms.
Spray.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
To Stop.
I got it wrong.
Actually recorded.
I have it on my phone if you want to
play it.
I recorded this thing.
I was listening to around us in the car.
Do you want me to play a short clip of
rammed us from?
Do you want to hook it into.
Well you could.
Can you do it?
Okay.
It will be better that way because I
recorded it just now in my car because I
was like,
no.
I got one of them old iphones with as an
auxiliary jack.
I liked the Auxiliary Jack Cole annoyed.
Why would they do that to Lightening
Jack?
Now you're assuming I can upgrade my
car,
my phone.
There's an adapter that allows you to
use an ox jack and the lightning and
there's an adapter to make steve jobs
rollover more efficiently in his grave
because of the whole idea is no adapters
sticking out of your fucking phone like
a second Dick.
If you didn't have it,
people wouldn't buy it.
I like the option for an adapter.
In fact,
this phone started sucking ass.
It's like crashing and shit and I was
like,
if I bought a new one,
they are fucking.
Yeah,
they throw things in the mix.
I believe that's a true conspiracy for
sure.
I think whenever you get a new iphone,
when the new brother,
a new iphones released magically,
my old iphone starts hiccuping soon as
that God damn I'm operating system gets
updated.
It's true.
And they force you into it.
Yes.
You have to sync my phone to the
computer and it was like,
you got to update your software.
I had been resisting you fucking bitch.
I was like,
fuck your ass.
So anyway,
I was listening around us and this was
recorded in the eighties,
maybe early nineties,
and he talks about Donald trump and
it's,
it's pretty fun.
It's only a minute long lit
hero figure within that mythic
structure.
It starts here that caught your
attention to Donald Trump,
for example.
Now you may snicker and not want him as
a mythic hero figure,
but he is,
he is a hero figure in this culture.
And when I look at that,
it's a little like,
um,
you know,
in those tribes where they take a maiden
and they honor for a year and then they
boil her or throw her off a cliff or
something like that.
I mean,
I'm not the Donald Trump myth,
not Donald Trump.
He's just a porsche slump that's caught
in the.
He's been selected to play out the myth
and he gets the feeling of,
wow,
I'm Donald Trump.
Enjoy baby.
You can have it.
I mean,
Donald Trump,
this is an obscenity because how much
the person close their heart to keep so
single minded on that while all around
them are the have nots.
And the people that are falling by the
wayside just because of the way he is
living.
That's kind of it.
That's a weird argument just because of
the way he is living because he is
living in an opulent life.
But if he wasn't living in an opulent
life,
the resources required to make him live
an opulent life would only help a
certain amount of people.
There'd be a great number of people that
would still be left in absolute poverty.
This,
I don't like that argument because I
don't.
I don't think that that's what's going
on.
I think there's a game going on.
I think he is completely invested in the
game and that game is acquiring money,
acquiring wealth and fame,
and he's really good at that.
And that's his game.
I mean,
he doesn't really produce anything else,
especially now that he's not the host of
the apprentice anymore.
Right.
I mean,
he's the executive producer.
I mean without him doing that,
arguably he's producing.
And I use this very loosely art because
that's what it is.
You're watching the program.
What I like about what he's saying is
he's just kind of stuck in the Donald
Trump that somebody has to play that
part,
the villain.
Right.
But I don't think he's doing anything
that's fucking anybody else.
Like I can't really.
I mean maybe he is.
Maybe is business wise maybe is how many
cars do you need?
You know what I mean?
Like when a holy man,
when you find out a holy man has 15
Mercedes Benz,
the guy who owns a bikram yoga,
that's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
He owns like all these hate what
happened with him.
But we see these other guys playing
these other roles going.
Like of course he has five helicopters.
He is,
he's a billionaire.
He do,
you know,
that guy's deal.
It's really funny.
He was being tried for tax evasion
apparently.
And they,
uh,
they found all these.
He had all these Ferrari's and bentleys
and shit and he,
his claim was that he was starting a
school for children and how to repair
automobiles.
So that's why he got these cars.
That's a good alternative facts right
there.
That's,
that's almost beautiful.
Such a unique case,
that beacon guy,
because they did an hbo real sports
about him.
I want to say it.
Oh my God.
You have to see that fucking insane.
He's insane.
I'm going to write that down.
He was talking about these women that
beat from Hud Noi,
Noi.
He changed his name to hot yoga,
Bikram Yoga,
last name,
right.
Um,
he,
um,
he was addressing these allegations of
sexual assault and he said,
you know,
that women will give $1,000,000
for one drop of my sperm.
Oh yeah,
that's what he was saying.
They were like,
no.
The woman who was interviewing me was
like,
what?
Yeah.
One drop of my sperm.
$1,000,000.
And that's like that.
Like oil.
We think maybe that does replenish.
He could really make a lot of money.
Imagine just a line of Petri dishes and
him just grabbing his cock,
like a bent garden hose and just
dripping out little drops.
One million,
1 million,
1 million pip,
pip.
About a billion dollars off my stomach.
Really?
How dare you.
This is the guy that's responsible for
this.
It's really so it's so interesting
because it's so.
It kind of embodies what's bizarre about
human beings because this guy's
responsible for so many people's
personal growth and enlightenment by him
bringing yoga and hot yoga to the United
States and making it so popular of being
this force because perhaps because of
his ego,
because of his desire to achieve fame
and fortune and all these different
things that he has gotten,
he's also spread this thing that's been
amazingly beneficial to people,
which has in turn fueled his self
righteous indignation.
It's actually kind of goes back to the
rioting.
Aride is a bad thing.
This guy being an asshole is a bad
thing,
but it's a bad thing.
Almost hoping to do a good thing or
maybe a bad thing that also does.
Have you ever met somebody that's a real
piece of shit,
but they also do a lot of charity work
and the charity work sort of masks the
fact they're a piece of shit.
Like that was one of the things about
Sandusky.
Send Dusky was this.
One of the things about him is that he
was molesting all boys that he was
helping,
so he ran this charity for boys and then
he was fucking horrible,
but it's something that people do.
They run,
they'll do something where they're doing
something very charitable sorta to mask
how shitty their our or to justify who
they are and there is someone in this
kind of fucked up scenario that did just
benefit.
You know what I'm saying?
There's someone who just benefited from
that and no one evil.
Yeah,
underlined.
It's one of the strange paradoxes of
life.
One of the weird things that we have to
deal with,
human beings are capable of so many
weird rationalizations and this is going
back to the diffusion of responsibility
thing that happens in mob mentalities.
You know,
with all I've,
I've,
I've felt it.
I've seen it before where people are
running around hitting people.
And when I was a kid,
I worked as a,
um,
a security guard at this place called
great woods.
You're a Massachusetts guy.
Remember Matt Mansfield,
mass,
Great Woods Center for the.
Yeah.
I used to work with Bob Seger.
Would put Bon Jovi I had been to,
but I've been to great words.
I think we see it.
So,
uh,
Dan Fogelberg I saw,
I saw Rodney dangerfield there.
Sam kinison there.
I saw bill cosby there.
I saw Bon Jovi.
Big of a venue.
Can you play before people start to go
like Rodney,
you,
you do get a lot of respect.
Like we all paid hundreds of dollars
here.
Clearly make respect.
No respect at all.
This was in the grill,
barrel of cash behind my favorite Rodney
days because Rodney used to go on stage
naked with a bathrobe on.
Wow.
That's what he did towards the end he
did.
He decided that he was going to perform
with a bathrobe on until he.
And he has like a fuck you,
you can't make just what I'm doing it.
That's what he felt like doing.
Liked it.
Like that feeling I like and he's naked.
He was naked.
Was it?
Could you see as Peccadillo you can be
guys who were working backstage saws hog
because he's like his bathrobe.
So he didn't give me all the time.
You have no respect place.
He's like,
Hey,
I put it on the sea of people who
respect me.
No,
I just think he literally didn't give
any fucks.
Zero fucks left.
He was deep into his sixties and he
would go onstage with a bathroom.
That's my dad.
I've seen my dad's Dick more now than
when I was a kid because he doesn't give
a shit how my dad isn't deaf.
He just doesn't listen.
Like he literally don't care because he
doesn't want to listen to him.
I told my dad to get a hearing aid and
he goes,
what could you be saying?
And then resumed watching jeopardy on
100.
Isn't that what could you be saying in a
row?
But I'm sure he was in a row but it
happened.
But anyway,
um,
I was there and a riot brought out,
broke out.
I was working and I was in the um,
yeah,
great.
Great Woods has a lawn for people don't
know.
It's an outside area.
So part of it is under like a roof.
And then there's this back lawn area and
Neil young was playing and uh,
you know,
fucking stoners and burnouts were there
for Neil young
and they started fires.
They started like little these little
campfires lighting papers on fire and we
had to break it up.
And uh,
I had a Hoodie that I brought with me
because I always knew I'd seen a lot of
fights and I,
there was a lot of altercations and I
saw one of the security guards beat the
shit out of this guy because he stole
one of the golf course and they hit him
over the head with a radio was like
craziness.
I saw craziness at that place and I was
always like,
this is not worth $10 an hour.
Like it's a good job.
Like to have when you're 19,
10 bucks an hour.
I was like,
wow,
I got some good money.
It was good,
but it was legitimately physically
dangerous.
And I was working with a bunch of other
black belts.
It was all like martial arts guys that
were working there as a security people.
And I was a at the back area where the
fires were and we were told to go put
the fires out and we're like,
you know,
there's radios were going off like when
people are fires,
we're going to break out.
And they,
they,
they canceled the show,
they stopped the show in the middle of
the concert because of the fires.
And then fights started breaking out and
I put the Hoodie up,
a zipped it,
put it over my security outfit and walk
right out the door.
Fuck this,
good for you.
Because it had gotten to that weird
place where like,
um,
I saw my friend Larry,
who's like one of the most peaceful,
friendly guys in the world,
told this guy to put down,
put down,
put down a fire,
you know,
get the fuck away from here.
And the guy goes,
fuck you.
And he punches the guy and punched him
in the stomach and dropped them.
And as soon as the Larry Punch somebody
so nice because I am gone.
I'm so out of here.
I just walked right the fuck out and
quit.
See in life we need a larry.
Yeah,
you need a canary in the coal mine that
you go.
If Larry's throwing blows,
well,
he was like the sweetest guy in the
world.
Get the fuck.
I mean he was a trained killer,
but he was like a super sweet guy.
So if him,
if he got to the point where he was so
on edge that he punched this guy,
I was like,
there's no way I'm fucking.
The guy might've called him a nigger or
something like that.
I think it was,
there was so much chaos going on because
he was black and the guy was white,
but he,
he blast this guy and I'm like,
if Larry's Hinton people,
this fucking show's over.
And then uh,
you know,
we heard something over the loud
speaker,
but the show stopping and people were
going crazy.
We can no longer rock in the free world.
But there was this feeling.
It was this feeling in the air of like
terrible things can happen for sure.
There was this feeling like,
don't get trampled where people are
screaming.
No,
not people anymore.
It's not you and one person.
So if it's like me and this other
person,
they'd be like,
hey man,
relax.
So we don't have to start this fire.
I'm going to get out of here.
Joe.
Have a good night.
That day when I got home I ordered like
two months worth of earthquake food and
I was like,
I don't like what we become when shit
goes sideways.
Well,
we kind of.
One of the things that studies have
shown is that in natural disasters,
people come together,
they come together and support each
other and help each other.
It's common,
it's really true.
But that the blackouts in New York,
yes.
It helps people help each other.
It's really like some of the best
aspects of human beings do come out.
What scares me is not that what scares
me is these unique moments where
violence breaks out and there's groups
of people.
That's because I feel like there's a
genetic memory that we have that's from
war one on one hand to hand combat
warfare because our ancestors for
thousands of years fought like that.
They fought in these chaotic battles
where you didn't know who the enemy was.
You're swinging an ax,
right?
That is so ingrained in our genetic
memory that I think when these riot type
situations break out,
like when that guy sprayed that girl in
the face or hit,
they feel like that's the enemy.
There's this instinct to just start
swinging at people that are on another
side.
It's in our bones.
Yeah.
I think it's a terrible thing to
cultivate.
It's a fairy and so in order like when
when you,
when you're establishing us versus them
narratives,
I think you.
You set an incredibly dangerous
precedent because I think you tap in
ancient genetic memory.
That's why I'm trying to say it's not us
and them.
I know it just sounds like hippie
nonsense,
but you're right.
I put it is send us in the stake of the
sixties was when the hippies were like,
it's us and it's them.
We need to get them when it.
When really we always need to be
remembering.
It's all of us,
which is why it's a real problem when
you just want to.
When you simply put a label on
something,
boom,
he's in knots.
I.
Right.
Well,
these definitely not a Nazi Punch Nazis.
Okay.
What the fuck?
First of all,
he's not a Nazi.
You're wrong.
And second of all,
if he was a Nazi,
how the fuck does someone become a Nazi?
How does someone become now like we
should probably figure out what makes a
person like that?
The idea that you just going to fix them
by punching them.
No,
you're going to start a goddamn war.
I'm trying to get.
His name is Christian.
I think I'm trying to get an x white
supremacists to come on just for what
you're saying.
I think podcasting can be powerful and
we need to have people that can offer
perspectives that you know aren't great.
Now I'd like to talk to somebody that's
reformed in that way.
Well,
long form conversations do reveal
certain aspects of people and you were
starving for it.
It's very difficult to tap into,
you know,
if you're doing seven minutes on a late
night show like Conan or something like
that and you see sometimes people do.
They sort of breach these controversial
issues and he like,
man,
boy,
you can't really do that service.
That's right in the next 45 seconds.
I also love it because sometimes the
joke has a two hour setup.
Yeah,
those episodes,
right?
Holy Shit.
It was like three tornadoes converging
at the end and we didn't know you and I
as stand ups or from a world where you
have to get a laugh.
They have 30,
40 seconds or whatever.
I've had some of the funniest things
ever happen.
Two hours into a podcast and it wasn't
even funny up until the end.
Until the end.
Yeah.
Oh definitely,
definitely.
And also when you're two hours into it
with another person,
like you know,
you and I haven't had long conversations
before.
So when we're having this long
conversation,
I get to sort of explore how you think
about things and you look at things and
you get to see how I do and we compare
notes,
we compare ideas and then,
you know,
my idea is get enriched your ideas,
getting enriched.
Exactly.
Sort of come together and this,
each other.
Yeah,
for sure.
And there again,
it kinda goes back to my google thing.
It's like boredom is good.
How I had so many.
I mapped out the whole worlds and ideas
and moving ideas.
He has a kid because I was bored as shit
when I see the screens in the back of
the head rest.
So the SUV is now.
I get it.
I,
I don't have kids and maybe that is
something.
You just have to be like shut the fuck
up and watch.
We there yet.
Are we there yet?
Are we there?
What do you want to watch?
Frozen but frozen on everybody.
Cheers.
It was calm.
What is lost?
There is something,
some people do well with boredom.
I went to a summer camp where there was
nothing and that's when I started doing
improv.
Well one thing for those kinds of things
you could put on educational programs
for kids and they actually do enjoy
looking for.
I put on nature shows for my kids all
the time.
They enjoy it,
but you know,
I think you have to engineer like when
you say boredom engineer's certain
amount of time in your life when you're
free from all that stuff,
put your phone away.
Well,
there's a jacket,
what is the Japanese word for it?
I'm forgetting,
but it's a value that they have.
The word means emptiness.
Like time.
It's not meditating,
it's not contemplating.
It's just all right.
For this hour I'm just going to be open
and see what happens.
I think that's essential.
We don't have that.
It's we're jammed up,
man.
We're jammed up and even more oil,
even more so jammed up when you have
more obligations and you have a family
and you have a job and you have careers
and you know,
you have a podcast and you're also stand
up and you're also doing a television
show with a fan because I just got
engaged and we're thinking about having
kids and stuff.
That's one of the reasons I want to be
married.
And uh,
how do you find it managing because your
business is you and your life and your
thoughts and your ideas.
I manage it,
you know?
Um,
but it requires thought and work and
effort and it takes away from some of
the things that I would want to do more
often.
And you have to shorter,
you know,
Louis Ck.
I had a great quote about being dad once
I thought was really cool because I read
it after I'd already sort of absorbed it
and then he and I read him saying,
I was like,
oh,
he's so right.
Said,
let it change you.
Interesting.
That's beautiful.
It's a great way.
Great way to describe it and not to
resist.
I think that because I know guys that do
resist and they wind up getting
divorced,
they want to be in Shitty dads and they
wind up being,
you know,
dad's divorce don't resist because my
wife left me.
That's what my hbo show is about.
What your first wife left you for?
Jumping right back in.
Look at you.
It was.
That was 10 years too soon.
Too soon.
How old are you?
I'm 37.
I got married when I was 22.
Oh yeah.
Well that would work.
I would.
I went to a Christian college,
like a proper youth ministry.
Major.
Chris.
Well,
that's what the show is about,
is about a religious guy whose wife
leaves and then this is kind of what
happened in my real life.
I got kicked into the deep end of the
comedy scene.
So people like Tj Miller and Nick Kroll,
John Malaney like rescued me when I
didn't have anywhere to go.
So on the show it's fictionalized
version
of that.
Every episode I'm crashing on the couch
of a different comedian.
Wow.
So you were 22.
You're hardcore Christian.
You meet this Gal.
She's hardcore Christian to.
Oh shoot.
How long were you married?
I was married for six years.
We dated for about a year and a half.
This is a true story.
I knew we were going to get married when
she went down on me because I could
because I was like,
you don't do that with someone you're
not going to marry.
And it was I wrong with you.
It was our engagement blow job.
Wow.
On bended knee.
Hey,
you were married and then what happened?
How did it go?
So that's what's interesting is,
is talking about letting it change you.
I remember before I had experienced any
sort of suffering,
I had a pretty charmed life and then I
experienced some pretty severe pain and
uh,
and that's when I started to figure out
who I was,
what I cared about and what I actually
thought was funny.
So it turned out this is very unlikely
thing made me into a much better
comedian.
Plus I had way more free time.
Oh,
well for sure.
It's gonna make you a better comedian if
you could survive it.
Like anything that's rough emotionally
makes you a better comic if you survive.
That's what already already laying is in
the pilot and he's in a couple of the
other episodes as well.
He's amazing and he's like,
it's good.
You're,
you're,
my wife left me funny now.
Used to just be like,
kind of cute observational stuff.
He's like,
you're a man now.
Shit happened.
And he's like,
true.
I'm,
I stabbed myself in the heart.
Funny.
It's like a different thing.
Did he hit his heart?
He's trying.
He stabbed himself in the chest.
I'm going to be at the heart.
Seems to be doing better.
I mean already.
Yeah,
he's been on the podcast.
He's amazing.
Yeah,
he's a good dude.
I was like,
call his next book,
consummate professional because he
showed up early.
Nailed his lines,
improvised,
killed it.
He's a huge part of why the show got so
funny.
Dude was very funny and he's a good guy.
Like he's a good guy.
He has this crazy moments and all that
jazz.
But.
So anyway,
he's got a good heart.
Speaking of Sabic really does have a
good.
He does.
He's a sweetie.
So,
um,
so she leaves you.
Yeah.
And how she leave you will.
She was fucking another Christian of
her.
Who's the other dude?
Another teacher that she worked with
found Rocco.
This is all names.
Rocco sounds like a bad play.
She fucked a boxer named rocky and I
actually,
he wasn't,
he wasn't a bad guy who used to like
each,
like we'd get along and stuff.
And then how long was he banging her for
before you found out?
Well,
that's actually because we moved
upstate.
I was,
there's a lot of elements to the story,
but we moved upstate because she was a
country mouse and I'm a city boy and
then we were like,
oh,
let's just live in this episode of green
acres.
Let's just live in sleepy hollow,
right behind the cemetery.
It was so terrifying and I just felt
this distance between us,
but I thought it was because she'd get
home at like 4:00
and I'd leave at like five,
6:00
to get into the city and time to do like
five minutes at some shitty open.
Mike.
So how far away did you live in the city
square and seeing each other?
Sleepy hollow is only about 45 minutes
maybe if you're trying to lived in
sleepy hollow.
Yeah.
Is it the sleepy hollow where the story
came from?
Yeah,
I believe that does a lot of sleepy
hollow's right?
That uh,
that author I forget,
is it or I forget who wrote it.
I don't remember who,
but I'm a dummy and I lived there.
I believe he was buried behind my house
and I lived on Gory Brook road chain was
all these things that are happening that
made it seem like a dream.
I literally would lay on the bed because
she's not there for me.
She's having an affair.
I don't know because I was just like,
it was the last thing on my mind.
Uh,
and I thought I was dead.
I thought I had died and gone to some
sort of weird purgatory because you're
in this new place and your small town
and she's distant from you and you're by
yourself up the steepest hill to come
home from a fucking metro north.
It took an hour and a half round trip to
do five minutes at UCB and I'd come home
and she's asleep and I just like get
drunk.
I was so sad.
I thought I thought I was dying.
I thought,
oh,
I guess I'll tell you a story.
One time when she was having the affair,
I called her and she answered the phone.
She was acting really,
really weird and like looking back,
the dude was clearly there.
Who knows what they might've been mid
boning,
I don't know,
and I was like,
you're acting weird.
And then we had a security question like
you,
like in Jason Bourne,
you ask a question that they know the
answer to and if they answer it wrong,
you know,
so I go up all the questions I go in,
what city did we get married?
So now not only is she whipped,
the other guy,
she's answering Trivia about our love
boy,
she answered it correctly and I hung up
years,
you know,
when we broke up,
she was like,
I just don't know why I answered the
phone that day,
but I,
I thought she was being burgled.
Oh right,
right.
I guess a burglary before.
And that's how naive I was.
Well,
I mean you just consider it kind.
I tried to maintain because on the show
crashing,
February 19th,
hbo I on the shot and playing that guy.
I'm trying and it's kind of Nice.
I like going back to that time when I
was,
I like to think I'm still a sweet
person,
but people used to think I was on
ecstasy.
You're definitely a sweet person.
Why would you think you're not?
I don't know how you're a grownup now.
I've lost my temper,
but you got an edge now.
I wouldn't even say I have an edge,
but I mean I don't fuck around with some
things.
Like sometimes like I'll get into a
fight with my mother because mom.
Did you ever say that?
I've never said fuck.
You mean that would be.
Have never said fuck him.
I'm learning.
The only thing I've raised my voice or
my mom,
I haven't raised my voice,
but I get angry in a way that I never
would have because you become a grownup
at a certain point and it's a bit of a
bummer,
but you're like,
Shit.
Yeah.
Like my mom always asks about my dog.
I have a dog and she,
we never had a dog.
So I honestly think my mom thinks I
don't know how to raise a dog,
so I'll tell her on the phone.
I'll just be like,
mom,
we're going to go.
She's like,
what are you up to you?
I'm just like,
oh,
you know,
a val and I are going to go get some
lunch or whatever,
and she's like,
is brody coming?
What are you going to do with the dog?
And all I'm hearing is like,
you can't handle a dog.
Like it just feels like this attack and
I'll just be like,
mom,
I've told you a thousand times,
so I try to make jokes.
I'm like,
well,
I'm going to keep brody into an active
volcano and I'm going to cut off his
head so he doesn't have to suffer,
you know,
while we're gone and she doesn't like
that.
So we butt heads in a way that we never
did.
That's interesting to know.
Your mom was at her idea to raise you
super religious?
Yeah,
there's,
there's definitely some latent
resentment there too.
And I got married because my mom was
like,
you should get married.
That's just true.
We went to Chili's in Burlington.
Maybe you've been there.
Children,
Tim Vermont,
Burlington,
mass.
Right by the mall.
I know Burlington coat factory.
They're more than great coats.
We went and I had the Nacho Burger.
It's Nacho ordinary burger.
And my mom was like,
you should get married.
And I was like,
okay,
that's how much of a mama's boy I went.
Wow.
Because I was 22,
I was moving to Chicago to do Improv
because I heard the story of Chris
Farley,
he moves from Madison to Chicago.
He gets us an out and that's what I
wanted to do.
So I was like,
I'm going to move to Chicago.
I'm not going to break up with my wife
or my girlfriend at the time.
And I didn't know if I,
if we could live in sin,
you know what I mean?
Like I didn't know if I can make that
move.
So she was like,
just get married.
It's fine.
And I,
you know,
I,
I get where she was coming from,
but I do think there's some latent like,
hey,
maybe it'd be like,
just live in sin for a while.
See how that goes.
It's hard for some people.
It's not an option.
You know?
Some people that are really religious in
the last thing she would want to do is
tell her friends,
well that's what the church,
it's the,
it's the expectation of like,
you can't have a son who's living with
this girl.
Like I was the golden boy.
I don't know how you were in your
family,
but I was like her,
like it was so clear that she loved me
the most.
Like she's like obsessed with me and
we're still close,
but she,
she kinda guided me in that way.
But that's kind what crashing is about.
It's like these things that you would
never ask for taking you to the place
you were afraid to go.
So she leaves,
you know,
how'd you find out?
She told me.
Well,
she took me to dinner hollow.
She got me linguine with clams,
which was my favorite dishes.
Is it really good?
A lovey and I still eat.
Hardly ever do,
but when I do,
yeah,
I know what you mean.
Treat.
I know he been trying not to eat the
pasta,
but when I do,
yeah,
it's almost worth it.
It's worth it.
So we got that.
And then it's,
it's a sad story.
She also took me to a liquor store to
buy alcohol for that night.
I don't know what's going on.
I'm like,
the puppy that's getting driven to the
vet to be put down.
And then we went home and she had a
left,
she had a script and she goes,
uh,
I love you.
I want what's best for you.
And I'm like,
Oh hey,
thanks.
And she was like,
uh,
you deserve to be with someone who
really loves you.
And I'm like,
I agree.
Yeah,
I'm glad to just not getting Jesus
Christ.
Number three was,
I don't want to be a cheating wife.
And I go,
so don't be.
That was my response.
And then she was dead silent and then I
was like,
is there someone else?
I said it as a joke,
like I felt like I was in a TV show and
I was like,
is there someone else like,
as if that could be a thing.
Her silence was deafening.
And then I swear to God,
Joe,
my next question was,
is it a comedian?
And she goes,
no,
and I go,
this is later in the conversation.
I go,
you're leaving me for us civilian.
Oh God.
See,
I love comedians.
How could you date a comedian and hang
out with my comedian friends and we'd go
to shows.
And it's,
I love show business.
I love comedy.
How could you leave the best thing,
the best people?
Wow.
So what?
I thought.
That's ridiculous.
Oh,
you don't agree with me.
You think that's stupid?
Well,
that comedians are fun.
I'm sure they're fun for some people.
The idea that the only,
I mean obviously I'm sure I probably
would've thought at the time too,
if you talked to me when I was 22 it 20,
or when I was 28.
I think when you're really deep in love
with something,
it becomes the only world that you can
imagine.
Well,
that now with my current fiance,
French for wife,
I don't know if it's a comedy bit.
Oh,
it's a comedy joke for bits.
Um,
I just laugh at that one too.
I will lend Jay,
you will kill me,
but I will lend you to you.
I'll get one good line,
jen.
I feel like any comedian,
uh,
is in a threeway there's something where
there's this other thing and it really
helps if Valerie likes to fuck comedy as
well,
and she does well.
That's interesting.
She likes traveling,
she likes the,
she likes my friends.
She likes it.
If she can get me a bed or try out
something together,
that's cool.
She actually can come up with some shit
too.
That's really fun to watch you do it.
That's got to be really fun.
Nothing better than doing the show.
And you know,
at Largo,
I have a monthly show at Largo and she's
sitting on the stage,
but behind the curtain and hearing her
laugh and I'm riffing and she'll,
she'll,
I never asked her to.
But God,
it really made me,
made our love that much deeper.
She just started writing down.
If I set a new line,
she just emailed him.
Wow,
that's cool to me.
And I was like,
Oh,
let's get married.
That's cool.
We should be married.
You know,
there's a weird thing that happens to a
lot of comedians when they get involved
in a relationship like a first.
The girl thinks it's cool,
like I'm dating this guy.
He's just.
He's a comedian.
He's wild.
He's so funny.
He says funny things and then it becomes
you have to work every night.
That's funny.
You have to work tonight.
Why don't you just stay home,
stay home with me.
I have the night off.
I've
been in relationships like that.
I have to,
and this isn't.
I'm glad this isn't one of them,
but I've also calmed down.
I wonder if you have at a certain point,
I'm happy to report to our species
comedians that I think there is a level
that you reach where you relax a little
bit.
You've,
you've gone in the fancy green room and
you've eaten the apple pie and you just
go like,
okay,
I've.
I've seen the strings at the puppet
show.
We can keep playing the game,
but I'm not as desperate or afraid as I
used to be.
I'm like,
it's a marathon.
There's ups,
there's downs and there's a lot of other
shit to life than comedy.
I don't do sets every night anyway.
That's kind of like A.
I'm like a three times a week ago.
I think three times a week is fine.
I don't do it every night either.
Um,
but I think the discipline,
when you are confident in your
discipline,
it can mitigate some of the negative
aspects of obsession because like,
you know,
you're doing the work,
you're putting in the work.
Like you don't feel bad taking a night
off.
That's right.
We got,
you know what somebody said that really
changed the game for me was live a life
worth commenting on.
That's good.
You can't just go out and next thing you
know,
you're just doing bits about motels,
hotels,
holiday inns and fucking airplanes.
I get that.
But if I just go to a concert or just go
camping or just go on a trip and have
not.
And not even thinking like,
could I get a bed out of this?
I can go to a sensory deprivation tank
and not go,
what's the bit here?
Oh,
salt on my asshole.
I'm not thinking that,
I'm just like,
this is life and that's,
that's.
I think that's the way we should be.
We can't.
There is this three way thing going on,
but I'm not as starved anymore.
Do you remember some balance?
It's definitely a balance,
but when you started,
that's kind of one of the other things
that show is about is that fervor that
you have when you're starting,
where you're like,
it actually got cut,
but there was a scene we wrote where it
was like if you're holding your
girlfriend in one hand and comedy and
the other which will and lauren lap
guests who plays my wife did this really
funny ref because she's like,
if you're holding me and you're holding
comedy over a cliff,
which one you pull up like the good son
and I had to think about it and while
I'm thinking about it,
she just knows she's bawling and she's
right.
That there's something.
I hope that people when they watch the
show,
I understand that.
I understand why my wife left me in real
life and also why the character,
the kind of pretend wife on the show.
Also left.
I think that's the same with rock and
roll.
I think it's probably the same with art.
I think it's probably the same with
everything that you become obsessed with
sometimes when people were involved in a
relationship,
especially when they're young.
It seems like your whole world to a
person who doesn't have this other
obsession,
like comedy,
like say if you have just a regular job,
you're working at an insurance company
or something like that and your
boyfriend's a comedian,
your girlfriend's a comedian and you
just want to get home and have dinner
and sit down with them and they have to
rush off to the city to do some fucking
sat and he won't be home until 2:00
in the morning.
Not Great.
It's not good.
It's not what you want it.
Yeah.
It has it in real life.
My wife said I don't want to be Pete
Holmes is why I kinda get it.
I get it.
Like even at the time I was like the
sex,
but I kinda get it.
Makes Sense.
That makes sense.
And then someone might want to be
though.
That's the thing.
It's like,
yeah,
no matter what there is about your life,
it's about finding someone who can
appreciate whatever that is about your
life and help you.
Yeah,
I know it's typically something people
say about kids,
but like seeing the world through their
eyes.
Like we go talk about the four seasons.
Okay.
You do a corporate gig and they put you
up at the four seasons and you and I
have done that before you bring the new
person,
the excited person.
It's so fun to surprise Valerie with
that.
It's so fun to go to the show together.
I just did a corporate and it was
brutal.
I got the back sweat,
dry mouth.
It just,
you know,
they're never great.
Right.
Those things.
And she was there and we laugh about.
It's like we should share the adventure.
She has her own thing.
She works for a charity called real
girl,
which is a female empowerment program.
Uh,
I know feminism is a cancer.
I'm just kidding.
But that's what she does.
But it's flexible enough that we can,
we can go to New York and filmed the
show and come to La and do shows in
Hawaii or whatever it might be.
That's awesome,
man.
You,
you found some.
I think I've always made this analogy
that people are kind of like the fingers
of two hands and if they fall together
like that where it's a perfect fit.
You're,
you're in,
you're in.
But a lot of times people get this thing
going on where you get those bottom two
fingers with the top two fingers.
On the other hand is a lot of wildland
fire.
Missed high five.
It's.
Yeah,
exactly.
You know,
it's funny,
the last person that did that for me,
again,
the crashing is about these stories of
when you're starting and when it sucks.
I really think that's kind of the most
interesting thing.
A lot of shows that I love about
comedians are about comedians when
they're successful and that's fine.
That's great.
This is a show about these times and
when I was opening for Bill Burr,
and this is 10 years ago,
I was in Peoria.
I actually made a youtube video of it
called Pete Holmes bombing where I kind
of do commentary on it when I got off
stage,
he was like,
you want it to be like this,
but you were like this like the whole
time just describing it to people you
want it to be like the hands intersect
perfectly,
but the fingertips are smashing into
each other and he was absolutely right.
You know when you're bombing and it just
feels like the words are just getting
sucked into a vacuum.
There's no connection.
Well,
you have no connection with it so the
audience is never going to have a
connection with it and it's impossible
for you to have a connection with
because you know you're bombing and
you're pretending to have a good time.
And here's the rub is my comedy
typically comes from a positive place.
Like,
um,
I like to lean into my sweetness and my
enthusiasm and wonder.
So if I,
like,
this happened I was at in Irvine and I
was onstage and I had this bid about a
Lululemon.
This hoodie that I'm actually wearing is
a Lulu lemon.
I just like Lulu Lemon,
who fucking cares.
So I have a bit about it though.
Like any comedian.
So it's my opener.
Sometimes I go,
this is a Lulu Lemon,
I just don't want you wondering.
The whole show.
And then the setup of the next joke is I
think I think people like ladies,
like a guy in a Lulu,
it says something about them and then
this girl,
this isn't the first 30 seconds of my
first,
first row girl big table because you're
gay,
you're gay.
And I just kind of wiped it out and was
like,
it's 2016.
How you're fucking ignorant.
Like just kinda like what it.
People were laughing but I was just
leaned into her and then I had to try to
merge back into my silly,
silly,
fun boy comedy routine.
I literally have a light in my act back
then where I go,
I don't know how to be angry.
It's.
And that's usually like a big laugh.
They'd already seen me be very angry.
You got mad when she said you're gay
because of a Lululemon lawn.
When you just assume that that's seems
like that's what someone would say it
maybe if I last for 35 seconds,
but you left the gap,
right?
Are you siding with this crazy woman?
It's a heckle,
obviously.
Never side with a heckler in the first
30 seconds and I'm doing the setup and
you go,
you're gay or was there someone on
before you?
Yeah,
the two opening.
So they were drinking,
so this lady probably lit up.
You get on,
she's been hearing people say,
shit,
that's marginally funny because they're
not as funny as you because of the
openers.
And she's like,
I think I can find.
I'm fine.
He says,
you're gay.
Hate is.
I think it says something about me.
Right.
That's so obvious.
Yeah,
you're gay.
Everybody would say that.
And 90 nine point nine percent of the
time people have the decency to go.
It's probably going somewhere guard
against the guard.
Against that one.
10th of one percent.
Yeah.
Come up with a better name.
You know what I can counter argue.
Don't do that for sure.
Remain vulnerable.
One hundred percent.
Get heckled.
Yeah.
Get some scars.
That's okay because I don't like
bulletproof comedians.
Well,
you're not.
You're never bulletproof.
First of all,
and second of all prepare for someone
saying you're gay because it's coming
again.
That Joe 100 percent.
I.
So do you have a.
Did you have a backup line?
Like when she said you're gay?
If I had been in a better mood,
maybe I would have had mode,
but I don't know homophobia,
like I hate the word,
but it's that homophobic to say that it
says you're gay.
There's nothing wrong with being gay,
so there's nothing wrong with being gay
and gay people are very fashionable and
someone says something about you.
Let's unpack that a little bit.
I do take offense at the idea that
people into gentler or more flowy yoga
meditation,
things are therefore weaker and being
weak is like being gay and being gay is
like being Frou Frou or like a ferry or
whatever you want to say.
If you make an offensive to a group of
people,
that makes sense,
but you're making a giant leap by saying
that someone is into Lulu Lemon,
which is really nice.
Clothes that make really good fitness
clothes,
sure,
and that that somehow or another is
weak.
I don't think it's weak at all,
but it's called Lulu Lemon Joe Lulu
lemon shirt,
but the point is that women assume that
men who are really fashionable or into
fashion and understand and appreciate
fashion yet,
but then times 10,
can we talk about black people love
fried chicken and watermelon fried
chicken is delicious because everybody
loves fried
chicken and large groups of people that
aren't gay like looking fashionable.
Right?
So what's going to be allowed to make?
Then I discouraged that.
I agree with you.
I agree with him also saying I defend my
right to discourage.
I agree with you,
but I think that if you are a standup
comedian working in a unit that sells
alcohol,
I feel like the student being taught by
the message.
That is true,
right?
I should've been like,
you got to say you left it open like I
would if I was your friend spur of a
second.
Too Long in the $30 to come see me and
you're like,
I'm going to fuck this guy shit up.
Well,
it's just natural.
It's a natural,
wise ass thing to say by someone who has
like one person at the office to do
better.
I want us to to do.
I expect my audiences to be better.
I want the clubs to be better.
I want us to elevate our game.
The people always like to say do better.
You know what's another thing that
people like to say that's really
disturbing?
The worst is the worst.
The worst is being eaten.
Asshole first by hyenas.
Okay.
That's the worst.
Anything other than that?
We really stopped calling it the worst.
People love to say that.
Oh,
Pete Holmes.
The worst that guys.
The worst.
He had a joke about homophobia.
He's the worst.
It's such an overused term.
It's so stupid.
He cut her term that people are using
today where they just throw it in.
Oh,
you're the worst.
I'm going to join.
You know,
I think people have arrested
development.
Literally.
They stopped for sure developing.
So in fifth grade you realize that you
could win friends by keeping your shoe's
untied.
You're a bad boy.
And also being like,
you didn't have the cool kid with the
untied shoes.
No Man.
Never.
Alright then let's just untie your
confusing as shit.
I mean Jamie,
you with them on this January kid who
doesn't give a shit as easy as you can.
Even just when it comes to shoes tied
shoe thing,
for sure.
The kid who doesn't give a fuck.
I'm older than you.
Maybe.
Maybe I missed that.
That's true.
The kid who didn't tie his horse to the
stable and that was the guy that,
you know,
he's a rebel bro.
His horse just wanders around.
The navy calls it with a whistle like
red dead.
I love it,
but forget the shoe tying into a
stretch.
But these guys that learned how to win
friends by going,
oh,
ms dot Johnson sucks.
Right?
Right,
right.
And then they just learn like sarcasm
can be so funny.
But I think so many people that just
misappropriating sarcasm by saying
whatever it is,
sex,
if I'm eating a Burrito in the bottom
falls out.
They go though it looks like a good,
like that's not funny.
You're just being a dick.
But in their twitter bio UC,
like sarcasm is just one of the many
services I offer.
You're just an asshole.
That's not funny.
Chandler are better with sarcasm.
Right?
But they probably are trying and failing
just like we try and fail with jokes.
Like Lulu Lemon joke isn't that.
But you know what I'm saying?
I mean all try and fail.
Gearhart bad you,
you hate as a lack of imagination and
you are stepping into other people's
shoes.
She was probably lit.
She's probably trying to be funny.
She doesn't know it.
Tape.
We're trying to be concerted effort of
someone trying to fuck things up for me
to actually experienced hate towards
them.
It was because of the,
you know,
you could get,
look,
I could go on stage in a bad mood.
It can happen.
Older women with wine.
And it was like I don't feel like you're
a friendly crowd.
It can happen.
And my opener,
who is gay,
Brian Sullivan Kinda didn't do very well
and it was just kinda like you guys are
giving me the wrong vibe.
And I thought maybe it was a teachable
moment,
but sometimes it's like you didn't
establish the moment properly,
you know,
sometimes like I'll look back at some
lines that I used to like,
but they,
they just didn't do that well.
And I'm like,
did I just get attached to this line?
Did I stop it?
Did I have a development in my standup?
Yeah,
yeah,
because I sort of got attached to saying
something this way because I had been
doing it like that for six months or
whatever.
And then you realize like,
oh,
that's not a good way to set it up.
I need to just,
I'll actually tell my babies,
you know,
that expression I've heard kill your
darlings that kill you.
Kill your babies in terms of creatively,
creatively,
you have to kill some of the ideas,
but you're attached to them because
they're yours.
You painful.
Yeah.
That's a lot of what writing is for.
Yes.
I'll go.
One word is shit on my own experience.
Uh,
when you craft an act for fans and I
know you know this feeling,
then you go to a club where you know,
Irvine,
I don't think the crowd was necessarily
there to see me.
Remember,
you're like,
oh shit.
Yes.
Stand up is more like boxing.
Then I remember.
Oh yeah,
because if you like,
if you watch my special,
it's all fans.
You get a standing ovation when you're
coming out.
And I love that.
I'm going to quote Sinbad said that he
goes,
I love,
I love this quote.
He goes,
certainly is a very nice guy.
He was great.
He did my podcast.
Tony Hinchcliffe says he's awesome.
Talk about leaving your body.
Astral projection.
Same bad.
Does it?
He asked truly projects,
astral project,
how's he do that?
He stopped doing well.
There's all these techniques,
there's books and stuff about it.
The long and the short is you get into a
trance and you imagine a rope above you.
Then pull yourself down or what he did
actually remember,
he was like,
I put something just out of my reach.
And then you're trying,
as you're laying there with your eyes
closed,
meditating,
you're trying to reach the thing.
And then he said he felt his hand
wrapped around it and that's how he knew
he had left his body and he did it for
months and months and months and months.
And then one day he said he was like in
this weird place he was in the cave.
Something like shadow creature came up
and hit him in the chest.
I know this is sinbad,
remember Eddie goes.
And it felt like someone had cracked me
in the chest with a sledge hammer and he
was like,
I never did it again.
Whoa.
And I was like,
really?
You got to go back?
Try and find like booby island or
something.
He's right though.
Maybe he's ready to be snatched up by
the demons and stranger things.
It is next dimension demon that lives in
the wall.
It is scary.
If you read a journey's out of the body
are far.
Journey is a Robert Monroe in
the fifties.
It's like you read this book and he
still calls black people negros and
stuff like you can tell it's an old old
book,
but he's telling that's how old this
stuff is.
It's goes way back.
He would tell stories about like seeing
something fly by and being very
concerned that that thing was trying to
get into his body before you needed.
So it's kind of a scary thing.
But anyway,
but don't you think that dreams and you
know,
moods like states of mind,
like the state of mind that you had when
you went on stage that time,
the state of mind that you have when you
have a fucked up dream,
it's like the ability to do that,
your mind has to change stances and
positions and that these stances and
positions really greatly affect how you
react to a situation.
So you're coming into something with so
much baggage and so much good or bad.
Like sometimes you come into something
and you'd be in the best mood ever.
And like I got rear ended by this
undocumented worker and uh,
he's a,
a guy was illegal in the country.
He was from Mexico,
he didn't have insurance and I had,
it was my favorite car.
I have a porsche nine slash 11,
gt three.
It's a race car to car to drive.
I've had it for years.
I love it.
It's just like really light car that
sound in this guy fucking plowed into
them and the engine's in the back.
Yeah.
And I was like,
oh no,
I was thinking my car's fucked.
But luckily he don't like when he hit
the brakes he was texting of course.
And when he,
uh,
and traffic was stopped and he looked up
and I saw him look up.
I saw him in the rear view mirror and I
saw his face.
I saw him slam on the brakes.
I'm like,
this guy's going to hit me for sure.
And he had a Honda civic and his car
went under my car because,
you know,
when you break dive,
your car dips down.
Wow.
So his car literally like,
ran into my car but kind of lifted it up
and sent me a flying.
Yes,
he sent me fine and crushed his car.
Um,
but it was luckily that he had a light
car and it damaged my car,
but they will,
they fixed it pretty quickly,
but at that moment I got out of the car
and I was in the best state of mind that
day.
I had been doing a lot of yoga and it
just,
everything was going good.
I was feeling positive and generous and
friendly and I,
I talked to him and I was like,
I go,
do you have a license?
He's like,
no,
I go,
boy,
driving,
you don't have a license.
And he was honest.
He goes,
I gotta work,
man.
I grew up and uh,
I called,
uh,
I don't remember what I called a tow
truck or if I called the police.
I don't remember what I did because we
pulled out,
his car was fucked.
My car drove to the comedy store.
I drove that night but I was going to
get his information and everything and I
was going to stick around for the cops
and tell the cops that,
you know,
this guy doesn't have a license and this
and that.
And I'm like,
fuck this.
I'm like,
alright man,
have a good night.
I just drove away.
I got so nervous that you were about to
tell me a story where you're like,
and then the cops came.
So I signed autographs while they
arrested this guy.
I bolted.
I didn't want to tell on him.
I'm like,
she's like,
it's 25 year old kid from Mexico is
trying to make it,
trying to,
you know,
try and make some money.
You trying to do better demonstrated
grace.
Well,
I also,
I was in a good state of mind like I
could've been in a terrible state of
mind.
I could have been ramped up,
I could have gotten in some altercation,
some dickhead at yet because of this
will fuck that guy and this guy hit me,
man,
what the fuck,
you know,
you,
you come into it already ramped up.
That's right.
But that moment made me realize like you
can go into a moment,
like if you could be at a,
in the best state of mind you can do
regardless of the circumstance.
That's right.
Well,
you know,
it's funny that you said that because I
had that kind of are.
This is actually just had an argument
with my mother and then we went to
dinner and I was in the best mood before
that I was,
I meditated and I just felt amazing and
then I called my mom because I was
feeling good.
I was like,
I can,
I can handle a call home,
got in a bad mood.
Immediately.
Val and I were going to dinner and then
we're at dinner and I'm just kind of
complaining about it and then she's
like,
what if,
what if we changed your frequency a
little bit?
She,
I don't even know if she used that word,
but she was like,
what are we grateful for?
And that's Kinda like where you were.
You had just been doing yoga and stuff.
We just started making a list.
It wasn't like it wasn't huge big
things.
It was just like,
I'm grateful that we have.
We have a car before we can come to this
restaurant,
that we have the money right now to eat
this meal.
I'm grateful for this body.
I'm grateful for the help and you were
talking about earlier,
gratitude,
man.
That's how to get yourself into that
place so important and to exercise
gratitude consciously all the time,
just to be happy and thankful and
generosity.
Generosity is another thing that's
really.
That'll change your frequency for sure.
I think those,
those things,
and gratitude also shifts your
perspective and gets you to understand
that,
boy,
I could be in Africa right now living in
the Congo and malaria.
You know,
I could be fucked.
I could be in some worn torn part of the
world where I'm trying to escape.
That's right.
You know this.
I think that's also one of the things
that people find so disturbing about
this trump ban on immigrants.
You know,
now they're telling you they're not
calling it a band anymore,
but seth meyers is the hilarious thing
where they were saying that it's not a
band that he showed all these clips of
pence and trump and all these different
people calling it a band,
a band,
the band,
and um,
it,
it hurts people when you know that this
is a country that was founded on
immigrants and this is a country that
everyone in this country was originally
an immigrant that was our native
Americans.
Native Americans,
by the way,
we're fucking immigrants too because
10,000
years ago,
this entire country was covered by two
miles of ice.
Okay?
I mean,
this,
everyone came here from somewhere else.
I mean is in terms of recent humans we
recent being the last 20,000
years,
everyone came from somewhere else.
When they do these genetic examinations
of native Americans,
one of the things they find is they,
they,
they share common ancestors in Siberia
means they came across the bering strait
when it was connected.
And this is just,
this is the price where people come.
That's our idea.
Yeah,
so when you're blocking these people
that are in one of the worst places in
the world,
Syria,
you know,
and then there was like this list of all
these Muslim countries where people are
allowed to come into America problems
and there's so many fucking people and
so many different countries that are
Muslim.
I mean it's whether it's Pakistan or
Indonesia,
but then there's politics involved in
that.
I think somebody pointed out that a lot
of like Saudi Arabia or wherever,
these are places where there are trump
hotels.
I don't know.
I don't know if that's true either,
but the real issue is Syria is the hot
topic and I don't necessarily think this
guy has the time,
nor does he have the inclination to
deeply look into things with a,
a greater perspective than what he
currently has.
Right.
You would think that,
you know,
Howard stern had a very interesting
thing that he said about Donald Trump
and I would defer to him because I think
he knows Donald Trump personally and he
said that he doesn't think that this is
good for Donald.
Like his mental health,
which I thought it was interesting
because Howard was coming at it like as
a friend and he said essentially the
donald wants to be loved,
and he said that that's what he wants.
All these people that love him and he's
like,
I don't think this is a good job for
him.
For his mind.
I know it's fucking crazy.
That is crazy.
I remember when Chappelle hosted snl and
he was like,
I'm going to give him a shot.
That's what we were putting ourselves.
Right.
Those of us that weren't on board with
him,
we were there.
We only have this one thing that's right
now the disturbing thing,
right?
There's not really a lot of other stuff.
There's this one that the ban on
immigrants is really.
It's an issue because there's families
that are coming over here and they have
children and you see them and they're
sad and desperate.
It's scary.
You know you're leaving your home,
your,
your seeking refuge in America.
You have a travel visa and you can't get
in.
That scares the fuck out of people
because you think that could be me.
That could be my mom,
that could be my sister.
Right?
That was my mom.
My mom fled world war two from
Lithuania.
There you go.
So I mean,
come on.
That's insane.
That is fucking insane.
I mean it scares the shit out of us when
we think that we could be.
So Zena phobic that we could just put
this like this blanket statement,
but let's wait.
You said earlier it becomes them,
but on the other side you don't want
what's happening in Germany.
You don't want what's happening in
France.
You don't want.
We have these people that aren't
integrating with the culture and they're
creating these significant problems and
you have like what Merkel is dealing
with right now in Germany,
this culture clash and you're having a
lot of problems between people and these
radical Muslim elements and they're,
they're isolating and creating their own
neighborhoods and you know,
and people don't want to integrate.
They want to bring a piece of their
country here and they have extremely
different values mean whether you want
to be critical of these people that live
in the Middle East or not the reality.
And we all know this,
when you look at the rights that women
in Saudi Arabia or are denied the right
to drive,
they have to wear certain clothing.
They have to have to look away when men
are looking at them.
I mean there's a lot of shit that these
women have to deal with that is a
cultural standard in their part of the
world that doesn't fly.
And if they bring that over to Germany,
then you see these men that are from
that part of the world that are in their
thirties or whatever.
There are grown adults know whatever the
age and that is their standard of
behavior and now they're seeing white
women in Germany,
these German women that are not behaving
then not acting in that standard and
they feel like these women are harlots.
They feel like these women are sluts and
they can just do whatever they want with
them.
And you're finding.
I mean there's not how many of them,
how many incidents are there?
I don't know,
but there's enough where it's a
significant issue.
There's enough that this is something
that needs to be discussed.
Like you have these,
this new element that you brought in and
how do you mitigate that without being
racist,
without being seen in public?
How do you,
how do you,
how do you somehow or another encourage
these people to evolve their culture?
Because that's a real issue.
It is very interesting.
It,
it did make me think of the word both
from Boston and the Irish,
you know,
segregated kept to themselves and they
were Irish neighborhoods.
It gets tricky when something is so
culturally different for us.
They do have a right to have their
neighborhood be however,
they weren't sure,
but for some reason it could be racism.
It could be just a.
it's not normal to us.
The way that they behave with women or
the way that they want women to behave
that well,
that's not racism.
That's a,
it's a huge issue.
I understand.
I don't want women to be sublimated and
what's interesting is that you would
think that that would be totally in
opposition of liberal values,
but the liberals are the ones that are
like really concerned with these people,
with people not being Islamophobic,
which is also a good thing to think,
but there has to be some rational and
reasonable consideration for the
cultural differences that are vast and
real and scary and also they're
incredibly restrictive on women.
Incredibly restrictive and on
homosexuals.
I mean what you're seeing with isis
thrown gay people off rooftops and in
Iraq and some horrible,
horrible shit that is the standard in
that part of the world and when you're
dealing with a culture that is just
perot programmed,
programmed for so long to be oppressive
towards homosexuals,
to be oppressive towards women,
like violently oppressive.
You know,
where they think you're allowed to beat
women.
I watched one of the most horrible
videos and I should have never watched
it,
but it was a a man and his daughter and
the daughter had been accused of
adultery and so he was going to be the
guy there was stoning his daughter to
death and he was the first guy to throw
the stone and his daughter was begging
for mercy and reaching out to touch his
hand and he wouldn't touch her hand and
he hit her with the Rock and then they
all through the rock center and I was
like,
fuck,
this is just a religion.
Just an ideology that forces people into
this and if you take these people that
are so deep in that ideology and so deep
that brainwashing and then you bring
them over to a free country to a
democratic country that has an open
policy on religion and freedom of
expression.
Do whatever you want.
You're gonna.
Have A.
You're gonna have a problem.
There's going to be some sort of a gap
that needs to be crossed and I don't
know how to do it.
How do you.
How do you make those people evolve?
Their ideas?
I just don't know.
Scary.
I don't even.
It's crazy.
So when you think about people coming
into this country hand,
we were new at this and there's gonna be
mistakes and there's going to be things
like that seem unsolvable problems.
There is the human life element of it.
We know that there's a basis of like
people are dying and they need help.
Yes,
and then we go,
well,
people that we may not agree with her
dying and need help,
but you still go,
we don't need to take lsd to go,
well,
you still need to help people that you
don't agree with.
You're right,
it's,
that's not the issue and the vast
majority,
let's be really clear,
are never going to cause any problems.
The vast majority are going to integrate
fine.
They're going to have friends that are
Christians and baptists,
Mormons and whatever,
and then there's going to be no issues.
The vast majority,
but there is going to be.
There's going to be a few issues and
when those issues pop up,
then it always becomes highlighted.
Oh,
it's their religion.
It's their ideology,
you know,
it could be mental health issues.
They just overturn something here in
America though that it was like,
it's no longer a federal or I don't
know.
I don't know the legal speak,
but it's no longer as serious of an
offense as it used to be to beat your
wife.
So no,
that was actually in Egypt.
No,
where was it was just.
It was just a law that was just.
Hold on a second.
There was just a law that was just past.
Where the fuck was that?
God Damn it.
I tweeted about it.
Oh,
Russia was in Russia.
Russia.
Yeah.
Crazy.
Like domestic violence is decriminalized
in Russia if it doesn't cause severe
injury.
We also,
what I'm saying is we also have people
here that are very backwards about women
and gays,
that we have plenty of them and they're
also here.
I'm just trying to advocate the Saudis
and a lot of the Middle Eastern
countries take that shit to a whole new
level.
I human aren't even allowed to drive.
Right.
I mean they have to have a male
companion when they go out at night.
I mean,
there's,
there's some unbelievably regressive
ideas that are just accepted because we
don't want to appear to be homophobic or
excuse me,
Islamophobia.
And then there's Bob,
uh,
I think,
is it Bob Jones?
There's a Christian university where
there's blue sidewalls for boys and pink
for girls.
So everybody's fucked what I'm saying.
Right.
But they're not stoning people.
They're not having a fighter.
Just,
I mean,
you just scarred me emotionally.
Honor,
killing.
Honor killing is a real thing.
Yeah.
I mean this is not,
this is not like an imaginary idea
that's never enforced.
It's a real thing.
So it's female genital mutilation.
He talked to Ian Hirsi Ali about it and
she gets labeled in Islamophobia because
she talks openly about the problems with
the ideology and she's a woman who
experienced female genital mutilation.
I mean she was,
that she had to flee her country and now
she's here writing books and giving
lectures.
And the hardcore left the far left.
Crazies are attacking her as being
Islamophobic.
But
you know what's interesting about these
very,
very complicated,
and you've just illuminated me in many
ways,
a issues is when things get really,
really complicated,
we do take comfort in what I call like
the slingblade mentality.
Remember slingblade?
Yeah.
So there's dad.
Alright.
Some people call it a kaiser blade.
I call it a sling blade.
So that movie is like strangely pleasant
in this weird way because the boy has
the abusive father and the mother and
they're being held captive by this drunk
asshole.
Spoiler alert.
It's from the nineties.
You should have seen that by now,
right?
Incomes.
A simple man who is a graceful
character,
a compassionate character,
and he kills the dad.
He hits him in the head with a sling
blade.
That's why the movie's called Sling
Blade and he kills the guy.
So it is this complicated thing.
The drunk dad is a person.
We could zoom out on him and be like,
okay,
why is he drinking?
What's going on?
How can we help them?
How can we rehabilitate this guy?
But there's something about being a
human that occasionally John Wick style,
you just want a guy to go in and shoot a
bunch of a bunch of people.
Just clean the problem up in a simple
way.
What I'm saying?
Punch Nazis.
That's what I'm saying.
There you go.
So complicated issues somehow attract
overly simple response,
especially because people are lazy.
That's what.
That's where racism comes in.
You Go.
I'm afraid that some people are
dangerous.
Well,
these guys say black people are
dangerous.
Ah,
I feel a little bit more comfortable
because I look around the store and
there's.
None of them would really.
There's a white guy that'll fuck you up
just as bad as anybody in that same
store.
But we're looking for these click
moments where we just go,
John Wick shot the guy,
go to bed.
And that's what I think.
And I'm actually trying to understand
trump supporters.
I think there's a slingblade thing going
on with trump where he's like,
look,
what are we going to do?
These people want to come in.
Nobody likes people dying.
But these people may be.
There's this threat of this changing the
culture,
changing women being bad this way,
violent this way.
Oh,
let's just not let them in.
It's like a panic answer,
you know what I mean?
And it appeals.
That was one of the things that I find
not too many people like me,
I don't agree with trump,
but when I would watch the debates,
I would catch something in my brain
going,
oh,
this guy's driving the car.
You know what I mean?
Like he was such a blow hard and he had
solutions that if I was quiet enough,
I could recognize the part in my own
psyche that went.
Data will protect us.
Yeah.
There's the appeal of the strong man,
a strong confident man who stands in
front of all us and tells us he got it.
But if we can admit that,
and I'm trying to admit that as much as
I,
then
we don't see my sister getting pepper
sprayed by my brother.
You know what I mean?
Like we're all in it together.
That's what I talk about.
Good discourse.
We need to go like Jon Stewart was like,
these guys aren't afraid of Muslims.
They're afraid of their health insurance
premiums.
That was such a great quote.
He was like,
this plan was fucking them.
They couldn't afford their insulin,
so trump comes in and he's like,
don't worry about it.
I'm going to get you jobs.
I'm going to get you this.
I'm going to get you that and some other
stuff.
Some hateful stuff is coming along with
it,
but they didn't have the luxury of of
being like,
well,
I got to go with Hillary.
They couldn't I guess.
Well,
simplistic speak and when you're in it's
coming from someone that holds the
highest of high offices in our country
is very dangerous because if you
simplify things and say them in sort of
a a just a kind of a block headed way.
Yeah.
It appeals to blockheads football game.
We can't go out there and when they
don't have to think now because you're
not thinking you're the leaders thinking
like a blockhead.
That's what I can think like a blockhead
to when Obama became president and I
loved Obama,
I didn't follow too closely,
so I'm kind of a doofus in that way,
but I loved the man that he was and he
seemed to do a good job,
but he definitely inspired a lot of
young black people to be like,
oh,
I could.
This could happen for me.
I could be the president.
Look at that example,
and now I do think there is a risk of
being like,
well,
look at this guy who calls,
uh,
what's her name of fat ass and a pig?
And he became president,
right?
Who are you to tell me not to bully this
kid in my class?
I could be the president.
I called him a homo.
I can be the leader of the free world.
It's dangerous.
That becomes dangerous when you have
someone who's the spokesperson who
speaks in like,
again,
these simplistic terms,
right?
But when you look at what Obama really
did,
there was a bunch of issues where he
didn't buck the system where he did have
the most drone strikes.
Have any president ever where he did
crack down on whistle blowers,
right where he did the opposite of what
he said and his hope and change website
where we wound up pulling that down
because he had this whole segment in
there about whistleblowers and
protecting whistleblowers who are
showing that there's some sort of
illegal activity going on.
Well that's not the case at all because
everything that Edward Snowden did was
show illegal activity.
I mean,
he's kind of exonerated Chelsea Manning,
you know,
so this is going to have that kind of
interesting.
That's why I can't pick it up or lay it
down.
You just have to look at it and allow
that.
There's some bullshit right away because
when I see Obama,
some great vine of him meeting a
basketball player and they do this whole
shake and play some of them and he's the
coolest guy.
He's articulate as he said,
and he's intelligent and he and he looks
cool and all that stuff.
Yeah.
That guy also that morning had a meeting
where they decided how many drones to
roll up shit.
Well,
not only that,
the Dakota access pipeline,
all that shit went down when he was the
president when they were making those,
those will.
They're cutting through private property
in arresting
ranchers because these ranchers did not
want this fucking pipe going through
their water system.
That was all in his watch and he
could've stopped that.
He could've.
He could've stepped in.
That's Kinda.
It gets overwhelming and then we go,
Geez,
everyone is corrupt.
Everyone's bought and paid for and
that's where you get people not voting
and that's when you get people going,
let's let's light a Molotov cocktail and
get somebody like trump in there.
That's what he seemed like in the voting
booth.
It was like status quo or brick through
the window and people were.
It gets overwhelming and there's nothing
more simple than a brick through the
window.
Well,
here's the thing,
another thing that you were talking
about earlier when you were saying about
arrested development,
and I do agree that I think we are in a
sense in as a culture and human beings,
it's.
There's a great propensity,
propensity to exhibit signs of arrested
development.
I think one of the reasons for that is
that we have to work,
I think working like doing a job that
you just don't want to do,
that you have to do because you have to
feed yourself is one of the most soul
sucking and mind numbing activities that
a person could be trapped into doing and
when you look at how many kids in this
country are graduating in great debt,
in massive debt because of student
loans,
and then they get into credit card debt
that sort bounce out their student loans
and you know they're deep into their
thirties and they're fucked.
They're in prison,
they're in prison,
and they're working all day doing
something they don't want to do and they
have to behave in a way that's not
natural because it's the only way to
keep this fucking stupid job.
They never get to express themselves in
a really honest and true way and
no mistake.
It's not a hippy idea.
We're all here to create.
That's what the world is.
The world is creation and we're here to
take our insides and bring it.
Well,
it's certainly.
I don't know if we're here for that,
but it certainly feels better to do
that.
I mean if you wanted to look at the
greater picture of organic life on this
planet and like,
why are we here?
Well,
I don't.
I don't know why.
I don't know.
I mean I don't think anybody knows.
I think you could come up with all sorts
of rationalizations for why we're here
and what we're doing and what our
purpose is,
but is that purpose really.
I mean we have a finite existence and
will give birth to other things with the
finite existences and during the time
they're alive,
the entire organism,
a super organism of human beings is
going to innovate and constantly
continue to innovate at this exponential
rate where we're going to be
unrecognizable and a thousand years.
We don't even know what the fuck the
human race is going to look like a
thousand years from now.
So I don't know if that's what we're
here for,
but I certainly know that if you want to
have a happy,
it feels fulfilling life.
Yeah.
Being a creative person or by creative,
it doesn't mean you have to be a
musician,
you have to be an architect.
The way that your appearance that can be
creative,
it's just finding a way to bring
something.
Could be a bay under the executive love
making cookies.
You can like making tables or clocks
like that.
A cool clock say to the guy probably
feels fulfilled as fuck.
He could be a knife maker.
It feels really good to be a part of
creation.
Does into an end or a carpenter or
anything where you're doing something
feels.
There's lots of
things.
I'm very interested in the idea of
giving us everything that we think we
want.
We want food,
we want entertainment,
and then you have people staying in
their houses that become like prisons.
I'm sure you.
I'm sure you've heard that idea.
It's like,
okay,
let's say it doesn't have to be the
Illuminati,
but let's say this world certainly runs
better when we can keep the cattle like
occupied and.
Okay,
so we try to put as many people in
prison as we can.
If you see like documentaries like the
13th and stuff,
that's one way to keep this.
This last year,
well how do we get these meds?
Oh,
well let's infect them with the idea of
consumerism,
so it's never enough.
Your happiness is always the next thing.
It's the next tv,
it's the next phone,
it's the next computer,
it's the next meal,
whatever it might be.
The next movie that you're gonna.
See whatever it could be.
So you're always in a state of lack
going to keep you buying more money.
You need more money,
you need these things.
Back in the day,
you know,
you read the newspaper and drink a glass
of old team.
Now you have to have a netflix
subscription and you got to have Amazon
prime and all the shit.
So you're in debt,
you're chasing it and you're never gonna
get it and then at night you deserve it
after your shit job to sit on the couch
and zone out and that's how you keep us
in line as well.
Yeah,
but I don't think that anyone.
I'm one of those people in engineering
that thing.
I think that thing is a natural human
inclination and I think it's also forced
along by people that are trying to sell
you the new lexus or I do want you to
buy these clothes,
or do you think wants can be encouraged.
I think we see that in other cultures
where it's not as consumeristic as
consumers stick is outward as ours is
like we're certainly surrounded by
advertising and all that.
A capitalist culture,
you know when you have capitalism and
you have people that want to sell you
the new apple laptop or the new android
phone,
they're going to advertise that phone.
They're going to make it appealing
because they wanted to sell well and if
you have a really good advertising
strategy,
you can sell more stuff and so your.
Your company becomes more successful but
you're not outwardly thinking or even
inwardly thinking you're going to make
more slaves.
They're going to make people that are
forced into this consumeristic society
and forced into this weird world weird
world where you're living every day just
to buy new stuff and just to get new
stuff.
It is sort of a symptom of the wrong way
of thinking and these traps it's society
set up for us,
but I don't think it's necessarily
engineered in a whole.
So this is a,
this is a thing that people gravitate
towards.
This idea that there's this cabal of
super geniuses that are running the
world.
I want to keep a stupid cheap.
I don't think that's true.
I think.
I think it's a self fulfilling thing.
I think we create these walls and we
create this prison.
We put up these bars and then we put
ourselves inside and we lock them.
But this is what's interesting about
mushrooms was something that's free and
something that has.
There's no mushroom three point,
oh,
you don't have to get the new machine,
but it is illegal.
It is illegal because good citizens
don't take psychedelics.
Obedient citizens don't know.
Was Jeff sessions was talking marijuana.
Good people don't use marijuana.
The same guy.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
And,
but you take that and you get a glimpse
of real life.
I know it's very,
uh,
kind of exaggerated and bizarre,
but you get a sense that what we are and
who we are fundamentally can be very,
very interesting and worth exploring.
So to kind of also to your point,
the people that make the laptop and make
the ad campaign for the laptop,
I don't think are trying to control the
world,
but I do think they like us.
We're also indoctrinated into a world
where you can justify the idea that I'm
just giving them what they want because
they too are,
are stuck on that hedonic treadmill of
like,
I need the next thing.
I need this job where I advertise this
thing so I can go out and buy these
things.
Well that's the case with television.
You know,
I had a conversation with a friend of
mine.
He was like a super hippie.
He was trying to tell me,
you know what man?
Fuck in the United States,
man,
their programming people with these
shows,
they're hypnotizing you to watch these
bullshit programs and you get locked
into it and it's all by design.
I go,
here's why you're wrong.
Fuck face.
I work on those Goddamn show,
so I'm going to tell you the funny once
you start writing for TV or like there's
no scale,
there's no.
There's no cabal of geniuses running and
by the way,
the people that are running these shows
are hooked on other shows there in the
shows.
I'm like,
I've seen game of thrones.
I'm hooked,
and they'll start telling you about all
these fucking shows.
That day was as much as I love a good
conspiracy like Matt gradings and the
and the masons,
and they're these clues about nine slash
11 and the simpsons and stuff,
and that can be fun and storytelling as
such.
Once I started writing for TV shows,
I was like,
oh,
this is just a bunch of.
Not Dummies,
but regular folks like strange marriage.
Funny.
If a homeowner comes in and he's got
blue pants,
you know what I mean?
Like right.
It's a strange marriage of art and
commerce.
You know,
that's what it is.
So you're creating something and you're
trying to sell it and as you're trying
to sell it then to make ads and they
make as stupid as what they're doing.
They're not.
They're not trying to sell like,
do you think coke coke is trying to make
a stupid?
No,
they're trying to get.
You'd think that fucking polar bales,
your buddy.
I'm like Santa Claus drinks.
They're probably just trying to sell
more shits.
They can make more money to go golfing
or whatever the fuck they want to do and
they don't realize while they're doing
it.
I do.
I think we want to enjoy this experience
as much as we can.
I think that's what we want to do that
at our best,
right at our best.
We're toasting,
we're clinking glasses were hugging each
other at our best.
We're laughing with friends at our best.
We're.
We're just having a good time together.
That's my favorite moments are me and my
buddies just laughing about something,
which is why comedians are so fun to
hang out with and that's why I can't
believe she left me for a guy named
Rocco.
We probably had a giant hog.
I bet he did have a dream to have a big
Dick.
Like,
yeah,
it's like a lot longer.
Well,
this is it.
When it's flat stock stock,
a couple of them.
This is him called pools and here comes
my cold pool.
Ruined or is there anything better than
gaining perspective?
I think there's a vonnegut quote where
he goes,
the best way to get in,
get over a woman
is to turn her into fiction and there
was something really Cathartic.
The sort of crashing is fiction.
My wife's character is completely
different from my wife that situations
are different,
but it was still really fun.
There's an episode with my parents and
I'm writing them saying the annoying
shit and my parents say it's not
listening.
My Mom's in love with me,
all these things and I was like,
this talk about zooming out.
You have like this weird dominion over
it.
They call cut and you just,
you know,
that was just pretend that you're in it.
Then it's pretend it was like 10 years
of therapy wrapped into a couple of
months.
That's amazing.
Do you still contact her?
No,
it's not out of hate or anything.
I tend to move on,
just move on.
I don't,
I don't talk to accept.
My Ex's is a very dear friend of mine.
Um,
but the rest of them you're just kind of
like,
it's hard because you're intimate with
somebody and you know you have sex and
you kiss and you hug and you want to.
It takes a level of maturity but to have
lunch with someone whose breasts you've
seen and just be like,
are you getting the soup?
Yeah,
it's hard.
You know,
and then you know,
they tell you they're in love or they
tell you they're getting married or
having a kid,
you're like,
oh yeah,
that's why I'm so glad my ex got
married.
She's coming to my wedding and,
and my,
and my girlfriend is very,
very close with her.
So I love it when it works out.
I never thought I'd be one of those
people.
Oh.
But it's amazing when it works out,
it works out.
It's great.
And the idea that it can't work out as
all silly too.
Of course it can.
You know,
I have friends that uh,
like one of my buddies dated this girl
and then he broke up with her and my
other buddy one I'm marrying her.
No,
their friends.
It's great.
It does happen.
It can happen.
It totally can happen.
Yeah.
It's just everybody's not right for
everybody else.
Yeah.
There's certain people that will drive
you fucking crazy.
But to someone out there,
it's the perfect person.
Well that's a funny tee shirt.
It's like,
no matter how much you love her,
someone somewhere is sick of her shit.
Have you seen those?
That's an old old statement,
right?
It's true.
Yeah.
Valid.
I have lived together for two years now
and it's just,
it's just been the best.
That's awesome man.
Because you found that thing right with
the finger slide into the grooves and it
works and it's like the idea that it's
like if it doesn't do it,
it's because someone's a bad person.
It just.
No,
man.
I can't say that.
That's something I try and stay on.
You made it weird as much as possible as
you don't have to hate someone to break
up with them.
It's good point.
I think you had to be throwing plates
and screaming at each other and
someone's an alcoholic and someone
cheats on somebody.
It's okay to say,
I do love you.
I may regret this.
Like just concede and be like,
but I'd like to go and that's okay.
I just like to be free.
I'll tell you this story.
I was dating this girl who for me seemed
very crazy.
I know that gets thrown around a lot,
but I was like,
I think this person's a borderline
personality,
all these different things.
I had this list in my phone,
in the notes file reasons to break up
and it was 35,
45 things.
It was insane and any one of them would
have been enough and I kept adding it to
it and go to my therapist.
Dr Gary Penn,
whose book is available now.
It's a joke I make on my podcast.
He's like,
Pete,
you don't need a list.
You don't need a list.
And that same week I had talked to a
psychic.
I'm not huge into that stuff.
I know I told you I'm a believer and the
psychic is like someone is looking out
for you in this regard in particular,
like they're rooting for you.
Whether or not that's true.
I held onto that and I'm driving from
therapy where my therapist is like,
you don't need a list of reasons to
break up with her,
and I'm like,
you're right,
you're right.
But I get in the car and I think of
another one.
I'm in the highway and I take out my
phone and I start writing down the 47th
reason to break up with this person.
Phone crashes,
restarts,
opens up,
everything's the same.
That's.
That note was deleted.
Isn't that crazy?
And whether or not that's actually
mystical.
It just meant something to me.
It was like fucking a.
If that's a coincidence,
who cares?
But it gave me the courage to be like,
I don't need a reason.
I want to bounce,
I'm going to bounce,
but I love you.
I love you too.
I don't like this.
Yeah.
I want to be attached and connected to
you.
I'm sorry we had a good run.
Maybe we'll let me the fuck outta here.
I know you should be able to like people
that you don't want to have sex with
anymore.
You don't want to be intimately attached
with.
And that's the other thing about people
like intimate attachments.
When you have intimate attachments with
someone,
like you have sex with them.
Yeah.
You share carnal pleasure.
Boy,
there's some fucking weird things that
happened where people get angrier.
You know they get fucking like the best
thing you can do.
If you want to really have a fun
relationship with someone,
and I've never done this,
hold off on the sex as long as you can.
Oh Wow.
I get to know the.
See if you really like each other,
see if you really like each other.
See if it's not just a thing where you'd
like should have been a Christian here.
Feels good inside their body.
That's what we do,
but he would court.
It's not the worst move.
The problem is we have this fucking
desire for sex.
It's overwhelming.
You know,
it's like this,
this ticking time bomb inside your body.
Then we'll convince yourself like,
judy is great to have these great.
Sure.
Convince Yourself.
Let's just fuck.
I got married to it in a bit.
We had sex before we got married,
but then he stopped again.
I know.
Don't tell him I stopped for awhile.
Then we stopped because you want it to
be good Christians kind of and then we
knew we were getting married and then
we're going to make the wedding night
special.
Held off for a bit.
I was mostly for guilt and fear.
Probably couple of months.
Six months as Christ.
Did you guys have cuddle or anything?
I think so.
I don't hand jobs.
Nothing.
I don't know.
I definitely gave myself plenty of.
I know that I got married.
I remember even my father who wasn't
very religious saying to me it's good to
get married.
Sex doesn't like you're getting away
with something.
So there's this latent guilt,
like getting away with Shit.
That's part of the problem.
It's so funny.
I'd like you liked one of the things
about married sex as opposed to single
sex is like if you're just dating
someone you don't know whether or not
you're going to hook up like you don't
know.
You don't know.
Are you going to come back to my place
like,
yeah,
those are the moments I remember.
By the way,
am I single time and I remember the sex,
but I also remember the moment where you
put it out there and you were like,
you want to get out of here?
Or like some sort of the early days,
let's go,
you know,
my is great.
Let's go get room service or whatever it
is.
And then.
Or when a girl says that to you out of
here,
I'm horny.
I,
I remember one time I was in Montreal at
the festival so I must've just gotten
off stage because I just so confident
and felt great and there was this girl,
beautiful girl.
I wanted to hook up with it and she was
like,
you want to get a drink?
And I was like,
yeah,
let's go.
Let's get into the room.
Just immediately get crazy.
Totally work,
no drinks,
drinks,
it's some people do and some people like
sex with some people.
Right.
But there's other people that you would
have said that too and they've been
like,
oh,
for sure.
And you know,
there's some people that would.
Afterwards we laughed about like,
who were you as like,
I don't even know anymore,
but as soon as I came I was like,
I don't know who that guy was that got
you to try on these sweatpants.
Yeah.
Isn't that funny,
man?
The difference in the way the mind works
when the cloud of confusion is lifted.
Well that's why I'm interested in like
werewolves and stuff.
The stories are so compelling.
I'm like,
Oh yeah,
because sex makes so much sense when it
makes sense.
Then there's other times every comedian
writes the sexist,
stupid bit.
Like every,
every comedian that I watched coming up
at some point we'll have the like,
what's that all about?
You put your Dick in the EU because it
is stupid,
but something like a transformation of a
werewolf happens and for some reason you
can't even eat.
You're just like,
I have to fuck.
It's a very,
it's almost violating something takes
over and you're like,
I gotta fuck,
I got to see tents now.
Well,
it's clearly DNA.
It's clearly the need to procreate,
right?
It's a biological trick.
What a betrayal.
The urgency of trying to create,
trying to read a book and it's like ass,
but it's also enjoyable.
So it's like you got to revel in the
enjoyable aspects of it.
I mean,
if,
if procreation was just simply this like
weird sort of pragmatic choice that you
made.
Well we're running out of people.
We definitely have to procreate.
All right,
let's plan accordingly and set up a
nursery.
Okay.
And then what are we going to do?
It's wonderful.
It's a fun game to be stuck in the game.
I remember that when I,
when I was single and I would hit on
people or whatever,
I would sometimes have to remind myself
like,
you love sex,
like I would have to [inaudible] you're
going out and you're like,
I didn't want to go out and talk to the.
And you'd be like,
like I could hear my being like,
trust
me,
I'm doing this for us.
To really be happy once when it's
actually happening and then I'd be in
the bathroom like he was right?
Yeah.
Son of a bitch.
But which is the saddest thing when
relationships deteriorate to that sort
of maintenance sex place where they're
just like that.
That's a lot.
Like a buddy of mine just got divorced
and uh,
I was talking about,
he goes,
just,
we got to this point where it's just
like maintenance x date night,
I guess we should do it now.
And it was just interested because there
is,
I've heard people that swear by that
sort of thing,
even though it's completely
dispassionate and it's not romantic at
all,
but they're like,
you have to keep fucking.
Even if it does seem routine because it
keeps you connected.
Like spirituality,
get it out of the way when you're
fucking.
Like,
I knew a guy who was about to get
divorced and he was like,
please,
we just need to have sex.
Like I know we don't really like each
other right now,
but just let,
let,
let's do it to see if it.
Because you have sex with somebody.
I would have sex with somebody that I
had just met and after you have sex you
just,
you just kinda like,
oh,
woke to the potential of how great they
might be.
You know,
you're just like,
oh my God,
I feel so close.
Well,
there's definitely some strange and it
was a communication through sensuality,
right?
This is like touching and kissing and
licking and fun and just all that stuff
like con contributes to the,
your appreciation of the person you're
bonding and some strange way,
which is why people get so angry when
you break up because it's like you're
taking away like a piece of them,
like they've invested in you and they
like their,
their,
their roots of like connected to you.
Have you seen vanilla sky?
Remember that movie?
I don't remember it though.
Some time ago is driving a car and she's
breaking.
Tom Cruise is breaking up with her,
so real nightmare.
She starts driving really,
really fast.
They ended up crashing into off a bridge
and that's why I asked to wear that
mask,
the whole moving.
Anyway,
so she's mad at him for breaking up with
her and she goes,
it's such as the perfect horror movie
moment.
She goes,
I swallowed.
You come.
And it's just film version of exactly
what you're talking about.
Like there's a bond.
Even if it's casual,
there's something going on where it's
Kinda like,
hey,
fuck you man.
In that magical place together,
you're going to act like that was
nothing.
I don't think sex is nothing.
I've had casual sex.
I've enjoyed casual sex.
I think people should have casual sex,
but their Qa,
I believe people when they're like,
hey,
that meant more to me than it did to you
male or female.
Well,
there's also this thing where people
were rejected where it hurts,
it hurts really bad.
Like being rejected her.
It's like one of the things that,
um,
I remember I had this friend and uh,
I was stopped being friends with him
because he would get real upset when
women would turn them down and he,
it was,
it was hurting him because he wasn't an
attractive guy and he was kind of
awkward and he would try to hit on girls
and it wasn't working and when it wasn't
working he would get angry and I saw him
deteriorate psychologically over the
years because like he didn't have a
girl,
he had one girlfriend,
she fucked around,
Ahm.
And then he just didn't.
He just dated for awhile and then he
became more and more bitter.
And what was going on was this,
he was associating women with rejection
and with that bad feeling of just being
turned down and despised like you that
like,
oh,
that devastating feelings to him was his
connection with women.
I think this is why we see a lot of
degradation and straight up aggression
in pornography for sure.
Mad At holding women.
It's kind of the grownup version of your
mother's tit going dry.
I'm not even trying to be frank,
I know what you're saying.
Colicky baby.
When I was single,
I remember very vividly because it
scared the hell out of me to be honest.
And this is kind of vulnerable,
but you gotta have good audience.
Uh,
I remember I was,
I was actually,
it was weird.
I was with two girls and I was trying to
make that happen and it didn't.
And I got in the elevator and I felt
like a colicky baby,
like a teething baby.
I didn't do anything right.
But if I had,
if I didn't have the self restraint,
I would've,
I would've been like,
wow.
I just felt like,
how can you not pick me up?
Right,
right.
Put all this.
You feel like it's owed you.
You're like getting all those drinks.
And I was so charming.
And you feel like a kid that got yanked
from love.
Well,
there's also the thing that we were
talking about,
like when the Werewolf kicks in and you
want to fuck so bad and you know,
that it could possibly happen.
So there's this moment where you're
like,
just to where we'll get to come out as
you get to come out and they're like,
you know,
and also will you love the like I need
you.
That's another thing that's happening in
sex,
right?
Is someone saying,
I see your animal side and I celebrate
it.
That's the opposite of a nun slapping
you with how bad boyfriend they want you
to feel pleasure.
They want you to come out and be
yourself.
That's how at the moon together,
like you said,
carnal,
and it's beautiful and you're there and
if you have added three way and the more
the merrier.
There's witnesses,
there's like a notary fucking and
there's someone else kind like this is
amazing.
You know what I'm saying?
That's healing.
Talk about the other thing,
like I remember pornography.
I think guys and maybe women to have a
certain shame associated with just the
functionality or like why do we love
Dick Jokes?
We love them.
They kill.
We don't talk about it so weird that our
whole species runs off of these fucking
little tubes that fill with blood and
common jet out from your body,
like a diving board for a mouse and look
and when you're watching porn,
girls are just like so excited.
So into it.
It's all an act,
I,
I'm assuming,
but that's why it's like I read this
book called pornified and they were
like,
men have ejaculation.
Shame because anytime anything comes out
of your body,
it's kind of gross.
You're just like shit or snide and your
Dick Sneezes.
This.
Where does this theory come from?
Ejaculation.
Shame.
I don't know.
I'm sure it was in the footnotes,
but I just remember that she mentioned
it and I was calling like,
that seems to make sense to me and
that's why you have girls.
I'm not even trying to be funny.
Guzzling come drinking,
come face comes.
Oh,
come on.
My faith.
I think it's solving takeaway.
Even if it's just ejaculations,
it's something going,
I know you're a wild animal and I accept
you.
You know what I'm saying?
Well,
I'm the opposite of grossed out.
I'm turned on by it by what?
But you know what I'm saying,
like woman.
Yeah.
I wonder if it's the same if you don't
know.
I can't think of a female equivalent,
but like if you have,
if you don't care that your girls under
her period or whatever and you love
them,
not in spite of that,
you love them through that.
I think that's also kind of in the
ballpark of like,
dude,
I get it.
We're stuck in these things,
these weird space suits that have these
shit comes out of here and he blood
comes out of here.
Okay,
all alright,
let's dance.
But at the end of it,
there's something going on somewhere,
whether it's between your eyes or
somewhere where consciousness resides
and that consciousness is also trapped
in these,
these desires and these,
these biological needs.
Yeah.
That's,
that's,
that's where Rhonda is really helps me.
Where it was like,
you just try and watch it unfolding you.
You're,
you're the witness.
You know what it's like to step into the
witness and your tanks or however it is
and you're like,
when I go,
I'm horny.
It's really the witness going,
Oh shit,
we're getting the horny signal.
Yeah.
I always thought that was my brain,
but I'm like,
there's something watching the brain and
interpreting it and the more I can be in
that kind of the yogis call it like the
unflattering candle.
Like you keep your consciousness still
even in the middle of a heated argument
or in the middle of some serious
fucking.
You're still kind of in the back
watching it like television,
like Holy Shit.
Like Ram Dass says,
great thing.
I think this is helpful.
It helps me.
If you're anxious or depressed,
you go like,
who's noticing the depression?
And you try and sit in there and you go,
there's depression.
Holy Shit.
I wonder if I'm going to make it through
this.
This is some fucking heavy shit.
But if you're there,
like,
did you read,
uh,
the power now?
It was a totally,
totally.
Um,
I listen to it on tape.
Yeah,
it's better on days.
He has that great point where he's
depressed.
He's,
he's thinking about killing himself and
he has this thought where he goes,
I can't live with myself.
And he's like,
who is the,
I can't live with myself.
Who's the eye watching the myself?
And then he slipped into that dude
becomes like,
I don't know if he's enlightened or
what,
but he's got some dope ass shit.
They say he does.
So do you beat home?
I didn't mean to go on a tear.
That was great,
man.
That's a good way to end this thing,
We just did three hours.
We did not.
Yeah,
it's 2:00.
You can read this clock.
That clock right there.
I've double up on clocks are clocks
everywhere in this place.
Back there.
I got to say I'm so honored.
I'm a fan obviously too,
was just fine.
It meant a lot.
I really appreciate it.
I really enjoyed our conversation.
It was really cool.
We kept other.
I also want to get it.
This is the hemp oil,
but is it maybe I told you about.
It's called Charlotte's web.
Oh cool.
It's like it's cbd without thc.
Oh Great.
So it's not psychoactive.
Oh Man.
You know.
Uh,
I know a lot of people that live off
this stuff body.
I take it.
Here's the great thing,
you can read on it,
you can do sets on it,
write on it.
It's completely functional,
but there's just a whisper of like,
I'm good.
Like you're a little bit.
You have a glow.
You're a little bit quicker to laugh.
Well,
the anti inflammation properties of it,
the anti inflammatory properties of it,
I'm sure that affects just overall
wellness.
Yeah.
Well they made it for a girl named
Charlotte who was having seizures and
the only thing that would help is this.
That's why it's called Charlotte's web.
You don't want this creepy d,
d,
e a.
we're dealing with this.
I know the tyrannical organization.
They're trying to make this schedule
one.
It's horrible.
It's non-psychoactive doesn't hurt
anybody,
but I can into my mom.
I can't give it to teenagers.
I've given it to great stuff and they're
like,
oh my anxiety's lowered.
Where can people find this stuff?
Well,
if you want 10 percent off,
if you don't mind me plugging in.
Cw Hemp Dot Com.
Cw hemp.com/weird/weird,
which is like my podcasts and watch
crashing.
February 19th,
February 19th on HBO.
Yes.
Set Your dvrs folks.
Joe,
thank you so much.
I appreciate it,
man and honor.
All right folks.
We'll be back tomorrow with Dr Chris
Ryan
Hours.